Exzellent Leute, auf geht's. Ich muss aber nochmal ein Streaming, also den zweiten Rechner hochfahren, dass ich was sehe, dass ich den Chat im Blick haben kann, deswegen dauert es kurz noch, der ist gerade erst am booten, geht nicht so schnell.
Wahrscheinlich mache ich jetzt erstmal Windows Update oder sowas.
Okay, die Musik ist mir doch ein bisschen zu einschläfernd.
So, jetzt irgendwas, was ein bisschen, ja okay, das geht. Ja okay, meinetwegen. Besser als das andere, bei dem anderen bist du ja wirklich komplett weggepennt.
So, wie gesagt, erstmal schnell den zweiten Rechner noch starten.
Wieso Commodore Hype und nicht PogChamp?
So, erstmal, hat keinen Sinn. Kann man beides nehmen, je nachdem, was man nehmen will.
Wenn man Computer hängt, was ist hier los? Was soll das?
Warum hängt der? Wahrscheinlich, weil ich noch Skype drauf installiert habe auf dem alten.
Der hat doch schon Skype installiert, ne?
Noch schlimmer, ich habe sogar noch Overwatch da drauf installiert, ey.
Was ist denn da los?
Kein Wunder, den würde ich auch nicht booten wollen.
Overwatch und Skype.
Ja, dann ist kein Wunder, dass er nicht bootet.
Aber echt, ey.
Skype ist echt.
So, nee.
Nicht auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall.
Irgendwo lokal in der VM.
Ich will das auch nicht auf dem Headset-Server installieren.
Das habe ich nicht vor, da irgendwie ZFS zu betreiben.
Ich habe mir nur überlegt, es wäre teilweise ganz cool, wenn ich schon mein ganzes System,
oder zumindest das System mit den ganzen Containers drauf,
wenn ich das einfach snapshotten könnte,
bevor ich einen Upgrade mache.
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich eh nicht machen.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, hat mich einfach nur mal interessiert,
wie so der State von Zipfel,
ZFS ist mit dieser Verschlüsselung, die sie jetzt eingebaut haben.
Wir haben vor Jahren, haben wir das schon mal uns angeguckt.
Mal gucken, ob ich das noch finde.
Ja, nochmal.
Archiv.
Mal Archiv.
Das ist wirklich schon ganz lang her.
ZFS.
Habe ich ZFS gebooten von ZFS?
Verschlüsselung.
Okay, guck mal.
Ich habe mir das angeguckt vor über drei Jahren.
Und witzig.
Möglicherweise ist das immer noch nicht überall mit drinne.
Also manchmal mahlen so die Open-Source-Mühlen langsam.
Aber jetzt habe ich nicht geguckt, wann war das?
Ich mache nämlich mal den Stream auf.
Da kann ich mir was abgucken von meinem eigenen Stream von vor drei Jahren.
Hier irgendwo.
ZFS.
Tja, Google.
Sieht man das hier?
Nice.
Warum gibt es denn den Stream?
Sibaro, was ist denn mit dem Stream?
Ich glaube, ich glaube das hier.
Na, ich glaube, das hier ist das eigentliche.
Alter, fünf.
Leute, ich habe fünf Stunden gestreamt damals.
Da hatte ich noch Ausdauer, hä?
Okay, hier.
Hier wird gerade rumgebastelt.
Ja, ja.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Ja.
Das probiere ich nämlich nachher auch noch aus.
Also hier.
Kann ich meinen eigenen Stream, kann ich abgucken.
Alter, haben wir nicht schon Musik, was ein bisschen mehr abgeht?
Nein.
Irgendwas.
Sonst müssen wir uns wieder den geben.
Das ist eh Pogger Soundtrack.
Aber ich will nicht jedes Mal den gleichen Soundtrack anmachen.
Try not to dance Challenge.
Okay.
Das ist kein Problem.
Ich danze bei fast nichts.
Okay, lassen wir das jetzt mal laufen.
Dubstep Chill Mix.
Nee.
Heute nicht.
Außerdem weiß ich da nicht, wie Copyright ist.
Game Musik geht eigentlich immer.
Bum, ba, da, bing, ba, da, bum.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
Oh.
Und ich hab's kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Ich hab's abgekackt.
So, mal kurz Chat überfliegen, ob ich nichts vergessen hab.
Was auch immer.
Ja, kenn ich.
Hab ich vor zig Jahren mal verwendet.
Stream Recycling, ja.
Ich könnte auch auf den alten Stream React noch gar nichts machen.
Ich versuch...
Ich versuch das mit der Native Encryption.
Ich wollte das mal ausprobieren.
Ich hab das ja vor Jahren schon ausprobiert.
Äh, da hat, glaub ich, alles geklappt, aber war äußerst experimental alles noch.
So, schmeißen wir erstmal die VM an mit dem Board.
Machen wir die Stream VM an.
Stream VM und dann, da kann ich das Fragenboard anschmeißen.
Alten Stream Abspiel abgehen.
Ja, der ist fünf Stunden lang gewesen.
Und ich glaube, zwischendrin war ich irgendwie eine halbe Stunde mit der Resonance.
Und dann bin ich einfach abgekappt.
Abgegangen, das weiß ich noch.
Den hab ich auch letztens gesehen.
Beheise, glaub ich, war das.
Weiß gar nicht, warum die Leute alle so scharf sind auf dem Windows XP-Hügel.
Angeblich, angeblich ist der Windows XP-Hügel nicht nachbearbeitet.
Der Sache trau ich nicht so ganz, ehrlich gesagt.
Irgendwie sagt mir die Musik heute überall nicht zu.
Ja, das geht schon.
So, mal kurz hier die VM anschmeißen.
Ach so, äh...
Was hatte ich denn...
What the fuck?
Der Desktop ist Poggers, sag nix.
Massive.
Ich glaub...
Hier war der Kram.
Restore Station, ja, kann man gleich machen.
Bam, PPGA Board am Start, zack.
So.
Hab ich noch irgendwas vergessen letztes Mal?
Ich löscht das jetzt erst mal vom letzten Mal.
Äh, warum geht das nicht weg?
Will nicht.
Jawoll.
Excellent.
Mehr Schrott Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellente.
Extrem exzellente Subscription.
Leute, habt ihr schon gesehen?
Mein Serverraum sieht langsam tatsächlich...
Benutzbar aus.
Schaut mal hier.
Übrigens, Ubuntu hat gewonnen.
Bei meiner Umfrage auf...
Twitter.
Okay, okay.
Ubuntu, ich mein, ich mein natürlich...
So, ähm...
Mit 65 Prozent.
Und zwar...
Wir hatten eben Xapt, ich hab's gar nicht gesehen.
Oh, das Scam-Train ist am Start.
The General Slain.
Zehn Monate.
Excellent Subscription.
Moin Albi.
Wie ging nochmal der Befehl, wenn man per Putty auf einen Server gehen wollte, der mit Lux verschlüsselt wurde und neu gestapelt?
Gar nicht, einfach PSSH draufgehen.
Und wenn du dann drauf bist, kannst du...
Äh...
Crypt Setup Unlock.
Oder einfach nur Unlock oder so.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Aus dem Kopf jetzt.
Warum ist denn die Firefox-Adress-Zeit so fett?
Ah, ne, ist schon erledigt.
Okay, excellent.
So, also haben wir mal einen neuen Fall mit dem hier.
Also.
Schauen wir mal.
Genau, ich wollte euch ja mal meinen Serverraum zeigen.
Genau, guckt mal hier.
Da macht doch jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr her.
Sieht jetzt auch ordentlicher aus.
Es ist aber noch nicht alles richtig, richtig nice.
Hier unten beispielsweise habe ich einfach...
Alles reingestopft.
Weil ich wollte den Kram endlich von oben weg haben.
Was meint ihr, wie viele Leute haben reingezoomt,
ob sie mein Unity Media Passwort erkennen?
Weil das haben viele gemacht.
Seid ihr schon drin?
Nicht NSA Zoom,
Navy CIS Zoom.
Aber das verwende ich gar nicht, das Passwort, was da unten steht.
Also umsonst gehackt.
Kannst du eine gescheite
USB empfehlen, ja?
Nicht die, die ich
habe.
Ja, ist immer noch Unity Media.
Wie gesagt, hier unten habe ich die Kabel einfach reingestopft.
Kann man das vielleicht noch ein bisschen normaler skalieren?
Hier unten habe ich die Kabel einfach reingestopft,
dass ich hier oben den 3D Drucker
drauf stellen kann.
Übrigens man sieht, mein Druckbett
ist ein bisschen
verkratzt schon.
So aus dem Winkel sieht man das
eigentlich ganz gut.
Was ist eigentlich, was ist...
eigentlich der eigentliche zweck von so einem kleinen raum denn das was du da
siehst genau das ist der zweck der steht hinter mir oder ist eine tür dazwischen
das heißt selbst wenn da was mit lüfter läuft höre ich nicht wie kommt man
eigentlich an die schlafsack jogginghose einfach jogginghose bestellen die viel
zu groß ist ja da ist jetzt halt alles mögliche drin was man so braucht hier
oben wird ein bisschen zeug gesammelt an kleinen teile hier ist der ganze
werkzeug krempel und hier ist der 3d drucker netzwerk zeug und unten drunter
so ein low power server macht auf jeden fall jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr her
als das letzte mal wo ich das video gemacht habe
übrigens hat einer von euch eine ahnung bei diesen unify access points die dinger
sind ja eigentlich dafür gedacht also diese diese eier was das für einer
unify xg
jetzt wird schon wieder fanchi nikoto
baby show
bis den teuer zumindest hat also so sind ja eigentlich gedacht wie man montieren
sollte hat irgendeiner eine ahnung ob das den großen unterschied macht wie das
so abstrahlungstechnisch ist ob das ob das wenn und wirklich obesschen großen
Unterschied macht zwischen an der
Decke oder an der Wand
oder auf dem Boden oder auf dem
auf dem, also ne, also
hinlegen, an die Decke machen
oder an, also es ist halt die Frage
entweder Kopf über
Kopf nach oben
oder halt, ja
aufrecht
an der Wand
Du fandst es an der Decke besser, ja optisch
oder vom, äh, von
Abstrahlungs, also da hast du besseren
Empfang gehabt danach
Ja, weil ich hätte, ich hätte ja die
Möglichkeit zu sagen
Ich kann, ich kann den einfach hier an die Decke
machen, ich mach's aber
wahrscheinlich an die Wand, Decke ist so
Decke sackt ein bisschen
Ich glaube, ihn an die Werkzeugwand
hier unten hin zu hängen ist nicht so gut
Ich glaube, Access Points mögen kein Metall
dahinter, hab ich irgendwie so den, das Gefühl
Ja, ja, okay
Da muss ich mal gucken
Ich hab hier hier neben noch Platz
Was, nimm doch die Dose
ab, was?
Äh, also ich hab, ich, ich glaube, ich werde das so machen
Ich mach den Access Point gar nicht in den Raum hier
Ich mach hier durch das Kabelkanal rüber ins Wohnzimmer ein Kabel
und da leg ich den dann hin
Ja, der ist von 2018, der ist ein bisschen älter, der 3D Drucker schon
Genau, und die Switche, die man noch im Video gesehen hat, die sind jetzt auch alle weg
Hier unten sieht man noch
Ne, man sieht eigentlich gar nichts mehr, ne
Das einzige, was man hier unten noch sieht, ist aktuell
das, äh, Unity Media Box
und hier neben steht der Mikrotik-Router
Ich hab übrigens, Leute, ich hab's übrigens geschafft
Letztens hat doch im Stream einer gefragt, warum machst du kein PoE
mit dem Mikro, ich hab ja diesen, das Ding hier als Router
Letztens hat mich ja einer im Stream noch gefragt, warum machst du kein PoE
und da hab ich gesagt, ich mach kein PoE, weil, also das Teil, ne, da macht er auf allen Ports, hier macht er PoE
äh, da hab ich gesagt, ja, das liegt daran
weil, ähm, die Access Points andere Spannung brauchen, als der Router läuft
Aber
Was ich jetzt gemacht hab
Ich hab nen, nen TP-Link-Netzteil genommen
für so nen, äh, PoE-Injektor
und, ähm, genau hier war ein Netzteil dabei
So ein kleines Furz-Netzteil war dabei, mit 48 Volt
und ich hab einfach vorne abgeschnitten
und hab einen neuen Stecker drauf gemacht
so, dass das 48 Volt-Netzteil jetzt da dran passt
und
und, äh, das ist das, was ich jetzt gemacht hab
Dann hab ich den Access Point angeschlossen
und musste im, äh, Web-GUI
musste ich sagen, äh, Force-PoE
sonst hat's nicht funktioniert
Force-PoE
und jetzt läuft, jetzt läuft der, äh, Access Point, der Unify-Access Point läuft jetzt mit PoE vom, vom Router
Also, hat, hat mal wieder der Chat recht gehabt
Hast du schon den neuen Wi-Fi 6 gesehen?
Ja, ich war sogar letztens kurz...
Ich war kurz davor, mir einen zu bestellen
aber ich hab mir dann gedacht, wozu?
Ich hab nicht, hei, ich hab nicht eingeredet, was Wi-Fi 6 kann
Aber hauptsache mal besteu- aber hauptsache mal bestellen, ja
Macht nen Unterschied, ja, ich werd's mal ein bisschen ausprobieren
bisschen rumrücken, das Ding und gucken
Ich hab irgendwas noch übersehen vorhin
1500 Clients, ja, die Dinger, das ist wahrscheinlich, kannst du wahrscheinlich Fußballstadion mit bestücken
Hast du schon die Stepper ausgetauscht? Nee
Also, ich hab an dem 3D-Drucker gar nix gemoddet
Das einzige, was ich gemoddet hab an dem 3D-Drucker ist
Ich hab hier vorne, man erkennt's ja grad, man erkennt's hier ein bisschen
Ich hab hier vorne nen, so nen Ring ausgedruckt mit LEDs unten dran
Also, ihr siehst ja, hier ist das Licht, das Licht kommt von hier, von hier runter
Also, das ist so ein, so ne Fassung hab ich ausgedruckt und dann so nen LED-Ring gekauft
Und den LED-Ring hab ich hier innen dran an diese, was ist das? 2? 3?
12 Volt oder so angeschlossen
Und jedes Mal, wenn der 3D-Drucker jetzt angeht und warm wird
Also sprich, sobald der Lüfter da innen drin angeht
Geht hier der LED-Ring unten an
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch
Ansonsten hab ich noch so irgendwas
Ich hab da oben auf ganz abenteuerliche Art und Weise ne Raspberry Pi Cam dran geklebt, wie man sieht
Sieht nicht, sieht nicht sonderlich advanced aus, ja
Aber man erkennt's hier, hier ist die
Hier ist die Raspberry, hier ist die Raspberry Pi Cam oben dran
Aber da mach ich die
Ich hab, ich hab mir mal so ne UniFi Kamera bestellt, weil ich die ausprobieren wollte
Fand ich nicht sonderlich gut
Ähm, aber hierfür ist die optimal
Die ist klein
Und ich glaub die häng ich dann irgendwie frag mich nicht
Hier neben irgendwie hin oder, oder vielleicht daneben oder so
Das mit den LED im Drucker, ja das ist echt praktisch hier
Ne, ihr seht ja, das Licht, das ihr hier seht, das kommt von dieser
Dieser kommt von dieser LED-Leiste, von dieser Lampen-Leiste hier.
Übrigens, weiß jemand, ob es diese Dinger zum Nachkaufen gibt?
Bestimmt, oder?
Ich kann mal kurz gucken.
Druck, Platte, Druck, Bett.
So was da.
80 Euro.
Falsch.
Das Magnetische brauchst du, dann was soll ich suchen?
Ähm, hier, Magnetisches Druckbett.
Okay, wisst ihr was, Leute?
Ich komme auch mit einer verkratzten Druckplatte, Druckblinks zurecht.
Kein Problem, es haftet ja noch alles.
Es haftet ja noch alles.
Ich habe gedacht, wenn es jetzt 20 Euro kostet oder so, kann ich mir eine holen.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass es gar nicht verkratzt ist, sondern dass es einfach nur dreckig ist.
Und ich müsste das mal wirklich ordentlich putzen.
Wie putzt man sowas am besten?
Alkohol?
Alkohol nehmen einfach.
Hast du schon angefangen?
Nö.
Noch gar nicht.
Ich habe noch gar nicht angefangen.
Ich habe noch nicht mal eine VMA erstellt.
Null.
Schau auf Amazon.
8-0-0-0-0.
Äh, what the?
Das gebe ich jetzt nicht bei Amazon einfach ein.
Wer weiß, wo ich dann rauskomme.
Irgendwo bei Monkartos oder so.
Okay, ich traue euch.
Chat, Chat, ich traue euch jetzt.
Ich kopiere das jetzt hier einfach mal rein.
Drucker, flexibel, abnehmbare Magnetplatte.
Nee, ich brauche doch irgendwas mit Heizung drin.
Excellent, aber richtig excellent.
Excellent, excellent ist das.
Na gut, lange genug geschwätzt.
Ich wollte noch mal kurz gucken.
Ich habe nämlich irgendwas.
Sind normale Gebrauchsspuren.
Echt.
Also hier neben habe ich auf jeden Fall einen richtig fetten Kratzer produziert.
Da habe ich das Bett falsch gelevelt.
Also ich habe...
Das ist vielleicht ein Fehler, das sage ich euch jetzt gleich mal,
dass ihr den nicht auch machen müsst.
Und zwar...
Dass ihr den nicht auch macht.
Und zwar, wenn man das Druckbett levelt.
Das macht man ja oftmals, indem man irgendwelche Testdinger ausdruckt.
Es gibt dann...
Hier seht ihr diese Kästchen, die sind eigentlich ganz gut.
Es gibt so Testdrucke, wo man sehen kann, ob sein Druckbett gescheit eingestellt ist.
Das druckt dann so kleine Quadrate und so.
So, und was ich gemacht habe ist,
ich habe mir das hier ausgedruckt.
Ich habe mir das hier ausgedruckt.
Ich habe festgestellt, okay, hier ist es ein bisschen zu hoch, hier ist es ein bisschen zu niedrig.
Und dann habe ich es eingestellt.
So, und das Problem ist,
man muss das im abgekühlten Zustand machen.
Also das dauert.
Weil das Problem ist,
wenn die...
Die Platte wird so 50 Grad warm oder so.
Wenn die...
Oder 60?
Auf jeden Fall ein bisschen wärmer.
Also sprich, das Ding dehnt sich...
Das Ding dehnt sich aus.
Und ich habe es dann halt irgendwie geschafft,
so halb abzuhalten.
Und halb abgekühlt und halb warm das Ding zu leveln.
Und irgendwie war dann halt das Problem,
dass wenn das Ding wieder richtig heiß geworden ist,
dann hat es dann andere Abmaße gehabt und sowas.
Also richtig kacke.
Man muss das wirklich immer im gleichen Zustand messen.
Na, zumindest habe ich es da geschafft beim Rumdrehen,
dass der Druckkopf hier auf der Platte mal geschliffen ist,
hier oben in der Ecke.
Das war nicht so geil.
Nicht so nice.
Nicht so nice war das.
So, ich lade mir mal kurz den Debian-ISO runter.
Gibt es das?
Was brauche ich denn überhaupt?
Ich habe so eine komische Anleitung hier gesucht.
Wir machen das mal nach der Anleitung.
Das da muss...
Was?
Gnome-ISO?
Oh je, jetzt habe ich das Wort gesagt, Leute.
Das Gnome-ISO.
Der Chat kommt drauf, Alter.
Psst.
Das ist so geil.
Jemand, der im Stream nicht dabei war,
der checkt überhaupt nicht, was Sache ist.
Rufi.
Um all die Leute...
Ich lade das jetzt mal runter.
Um all die Leute einzuweihen,
die nicht dabei waren.
Okay.
Ich soll ernsthaft...
Die wollen ernsthaft, dass ich den Debian-Server
von einem Gnome installiere?
Okay, ich mache das jetzt einfach.
Was auch immer die sagen.
Okay.
Also während er das runterlädt.
Mal ganz kurz...
Da lese ich die restlichen Sachen im Chat.
Um die Leute einzuweihen,
die da nicht dabei waren.
Und zwar...
Ich hatte mal...
Ich hatte mal einen Kollege...
Auf der Arbeit.
Den haben wir...
Der ist ein bisschen durchgedreht mit der Zeit.
Und zwar...
Den haben die damals eingekauft.
Also typische...
Typische Büste.
Typische Business-Stonks-Entscheidung war das wieder.
Den haben die eingekauft, weil die...
Lustigerweise passt eigentlich heute richtig gut zum Thema.
Weil die Solaris und ZFS machen wollten.
Mal ganz kurz bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Und dann haben die den eingekauft.
Und als der dann da war,
ist ihnen eingefallen,
wir haben den jetzt für ein halbes Jahr eingekauft,
aber wir machen jetzt gar kein Solaris und ZFS mehr.
Also typische...
Typische Business-Stonks.
Typische Business-Entscheidung wieder.
Irgendwas gesagt, dann geplant und dann nicht gemacht, ja.
So.
Und der Typ, der ist mit der Zeit ein bisschen durchgedreht,
weil der war dann am Start,
war eigentlich Experte für Solaris und ZFS
und musste dann irgendwelche ganz anderen Sachen machen.
Und der ist dann...
Der hat dann quasi von Woche zu Woche,
konntest du zugucken,
wie der Typ immer mehr durchgedreht ist im Kopf.
Und der hat das irgendwie so geschafft,
seinen Desktop so einzustellen,
dass wenn er mit der Mauszeige
an den Bildschirmrand gekommen ist,
dass dann sein PC-Speaker gesummt hat.
Also der ist dann mit der Mauszeige
an den Bildschirmrand gekommen
und dann hat sein PC-Speaker gemacht.
Und daraufhin hat er dann immer das Ganze
auf seinen Gnome-Desktop geschoben
und hat dann immer gesagt,
der scheiß Gnome.
Das war dann irgendwann so der Running-Gag.
Also der Typ, der hat wirklich
Dachschaden gehabt mit der Zeit, ja.
Und es wurde dann...
Und es wurde dann noch schlimmer.
Irgendwann hat er dann angefangen,
alle möglichen Sachen
merkwürdig auszusprechen
und dann hat er irgendwelche Ruby-Skripte gemacht
und dann saß er dann wirklich vorm Rechner
und hat dann quasi gesagt,
Ruby, der scheiß Gnome.
Das war echt voll fein.
Der Typ ist wirklich zunehmend
von Woche zu Woche immer mehr abgedreht.
So, und dann...
Daher kommt das halt.
Das habe ich vor einer Weile schon mal erzählt.
Irgendwie fand das der Chat so geil,
dass die immer im Chat...
Dass jetzt immer mindestens einer im Chat schreibt,
wenn ich sage, Gnome, der scheiß Gnome, ja.
Aus welchem Grund macht man das?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe absolut keinen blassen Schimmer,
warum man seinen Desktop so einstellt.
So, also, kurz, kurz.
Cute, cute Chat lesen.
Irgendwas war da doch vorhin.
Warten wir schon.
Doch, doch, doch, doch.
Das geht per SSH.
Das habe ich vor drei Jahren im Stream schon gemacht,
aber ich weiß nicht mehr, wie.
Ja, wie gesagt, nicht die USV, die ich habe, die sagt.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich auch nicht.
Wobei, warum habe ich denn meine VR mit dem Pepega-Board an?
Kann ich doch hier reingucken, was die Leute geschrieben haben.
Siehste?
Ja.
Doch, doch, das geht angeblich schon.
Okay, muss ich mal gucken.
Alles darüber zerstört die Platte,
wegen dafür kann ich dir 3D-Lack...
Aha.
Ja.
Ich hatte auch mal eine ganze Weile ZFS, äh, Dings bei mir am Laufen.
War aber schon wieder her und das war total Oversized für mich,
aber ich wollte es mir jetzt einfach mal wieder angucken.
Ubuntu geht auch.
Okay, ich werde es jetzt gleich sehen.
Ha?
Download kaputt?
Ja, der Download.
Lol, das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Der Download ist kaputt.
So ist auch immer.
Ich kann die 3060 nicht zum Preis-Champ hinzufügen, weil...
...sich doch kaum Shops-Links dazu haben.
Okay, also, wir legen jetzt die VM an.
Easy.
Auf geht's.
VM.
New.
Custom.
Workstation.
Alles klar.
Installer-Disk machen wir später selbst.
Linux.
Debian.
64-Bit.
Ähm, das Ganze erstellen wir aber nicht da, sondern auf E.
Nicht auf D, auf E.
E.
VMs.
Cag-Weight.
Next.
CPUs.
4, wenn schon, dann richtig.
Fangen wir mal an.
1 und 4 Cores.
RAM 4096.
Bam.
NAT.
Next.
Pawn. Bam.
I finished installing.
Äh, live.
Alles klar.
So, jetzt muss ich erstmal kurz gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Stretch. Guest.
Ja, wunderbar.
So, also jetzt muss ich mir erstmal
die Anleitung aufmachen,
wie das Ganze hier funktioniert.
Pettifold nimmt sich setup auf. Ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ich weiß.
Aber es ist ja auch
ein Gerücht, dass man so ultra viel RAM braucht.
Also, die...
Bei FreeNAS ist das
witzig, oder generell auch
im Forum und sowas,
da kommen die Leute dann an, irgendwie mit
was ist das?
Einen Gigabyte?
Pro Gigabyte?
Oder irgendwie so. Es gibt da so ganz komische
Regeln, dass du am Ende dann auch im Heimbereich
irgendwie einen neuen Schee brauchen würdest
oder sowas, dass alle schwach sind.
Der Kram, der läuft auch mit
weniger RAM. Natürlich nicht
für ein Büro,
wo alle Leute
gleichzeitig drauf zugreifen.
Ja, und auch nicht, wenn man die Duplication macht
oder sowas. Das ist...
Ja gut, für die Duplication braucht man
extrem viel RAM.
Und, also das ist total übertrieben.
Das braucht man eigentlich gar nicht, wenn man da nur
nix macht und einmal im Monat
drauf zugreift, ja.
Wenn man natürlich gewisse Performance
gewährleisten will und Leute parallel
drauf zugreifen, ist das wieder was anderes.
Ja, denn der gleiche Kram wie ECC-Only
ist ja auch Schwachsinn.
Es ist auf jeden Fall...
Also es ist sinnvoll, ECC-RAM zu nehmen,
wenn man ein System hat, das das kann.
Ja, aber das wird auch
nicht unsicherer dadurch, wie andere
Filesysteme, wenn man kein ECC-RAM hat.
Wieso? Das sollte eigentlich
ISNI-Direkt-CPU-Support
mäßig sein.
Ja, schauen wir mal.
Ja, das... Es macht auch...
Ja, genau. Es macht überhaupt keine Probleme.
Äh, Windows-V habe ich
ausgeschaltet, dass ich nix leake, falls ich
irgendwelche Passwörter mal kopieren muss und sowas.
Das sehe ich als Streaming-Setup hier.
Hopp, Mayat. Dankeschön.
Zwei Monate. Big-Brain-Subscription.
Das ist kaputt, das wundert mich nicht.
Ähm, genau. Also, wo habe ich
jetzt hier die Anleitung? Da, bam. Okay.
Bla, bla, bla.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Okay, Step.
Prepare install environment.
Boot Debian Linux.
Oh, das ist hier das, dass der Stallman sich nicht
aufregt. Debian
GNU Linux, bitteschön, ja.
Es ist nicht etwa einfach nur
Debian oder Linux. Es ist...
Debian GNU Linux.
Gibt ja so, so, ähm,
sagen wir mal, wie soll man das sagen, so
etwas, äh,
ja, Leute, die so Grundsatzdiskussionen
mögen, da ist
das, wenn man da nicht, äh,
GNU Linux dabei sagt, dann...
Naja.
Okay, if prompted, login, user,
Passwort live, connect your system to internet.
Ja, ja, ja, okay, alles klar. Also,
ich soll einloggen mit User live.
Bam, muss ich nicht.
Alles klar. Oh, hohe Aufmerksamkeit.
Auflösung, hohe Auflösung.
Boot, Debian,
da haben wir doch schon, User live, okay.
Setup and update repos. Also,
das muss ich da jetzt eintragen.
Wir machen jetzt Trick 17. Wir installieren jetzt
VMware Tools, dass ich ordentlich Copy-Pasten kann.
Mal gucken, ob wir das live machen. Wie krieg ich überhaupt
ein Terminal?
Terminal. Excellent.
Kann man hier die Auflösung irgendwie ändern?
Ich mein, das ist GNOME,
da weiß man nie, ob es funktioniert.
Äh, kann man die auf...
Wie lö... Ey!
Hat jemand einen Plan, wie man in GNOME
die Auflösung ändert?
Display, da war es. Wart mal.
Ist auch geil. Ne, eines der wichtigsten Sachen
ist natürlich hier unter Devices versteckt.
Okay, die ordentliche
Auflösung gibt es schon mal nicht. Wir installieren uns jetzt
einfach VMware Tools. Easy.
Zudo. Oh, ey!
Cocona-Tastatur.
Open VM. Da können wir wenigstens
Copy-Pasten.
Wie, gibt's nicht?
VM? Ah, ne, ich hab gar keine
Auto-Vervollständigung. Open.
Tja, die Debian
ISO. Open VM
Tools. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das schreibt.
Up-Search. VM-Tools.
VM.
Tools. Oh, Mann.
Ich brauch keine Cocona-Tastatur.
Please. Ah, ja, hier.
Okay, Up-Install.
Open VM-Tools.
Deskob.
Zack.
Tastatur umstellen. Das ist ja jetzt.
Zack. Maus. Keyboard.
Äh.
Is.
Äh. Wie. Alter,
Known, please. Wie stellt man hier sowas ein?
Ähm.
Language?
Input-Sources. Jawoll.
Alles klar.
German.
Ah, ich darf nix adden.
Ja.
Wunderbar.
So, und jetzt Englisch weg.
Zack.
Haben wir es jetzt auf Deutsch?
Ja, yes.
Okay. Open VM-Tools haben wir installiert.
Dann sollte ich eigentlich jetzt ein Fullscreen bekommen,
wenn das richtig.
Oder geht das?
Ah, wir müssen noch. Okay.
System. CTL. Start.
VM.
Äh. VM-Tools. D. Oder sowas.
Ne?
Ach, meine Güte.
Äh.
Ähm. Open VM-Tools.
Nope.
Äh.
Äh. Äh. Wie ging das nochmal? System. CTL. Lists.
List. Units. Oder sowas.
Genau.
Äh.
Live-Tools?
Hat er das jetzt ordentlich installiert? Was muss ich denn starten?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann nicht rebooten. Das ist eine Live-CD.
Ich will einfach nur copy-pasten können auf der Live-CD.
Open VM-Tools.
Was? Ist es Open-VM-Tools?
Ja, oder?
Okay.
Okay. Lass uns jetzt.
Lass uns jetzt von VMWare erklären.
Ja, ey.
Diese VMWare-Artikel sind immer so super hilfreich.
Ups.
Abstand.
Lull.
Ah. Easy. Nice.
Alles klar. Passt.
Ja, komm. Macht man es richtig.
Funktioniert es auch. Sehr. Okay.
Jetzt können wir uns nämlich die Anleitung sogar hier rein kopieren.
Und dann easy, easy as fuck.
Bam.
Systema. Live-CD. Copy-Paste. So muss das sein.
Also.
Hier sind wir stehen geblieben.
So. Also.
Bootdings. Setup and Update Repositories.
Okay. Wir machen erstmal das Ding ein bisschen größer.
Und das Allerwichtigste. Wir brauchen...
Äh.
Wo ist die Font-Size?
Ach, da.
Ich brauch ein bisschen größere Font.
Bin ja schon alt.
Und...
Wir machen irgendwie was...
Ja, so. Okay.
Geht das bei Virtualbox?
Ja, das muss bei Virtualbox genauso gehen.
Hehehehehe.
Wupphaut. Ja. So.
Also. Okay.
Dann machen wir das jetzt mal. Ich mach jetzt einfach mal richtig...
Anleitungs-Low-Bob.
Setup and Update Repos.
Mach ich. Bam.
Äh. Okay.
Also das kann ich wieder rausschmeißen. Alles klar.
Update Repos.
Update.
Optional Installer OpenSSH Server.
Äh. Die Idee ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht.
Da kann ich das vom zweiten System aus machen.
Ist vielleicht gar nicht so doof.
Also der Witz hat...
Der Witz hat echt langsam so ein Bart schon.
Das kannst du nicht bei jedem Song bringen.
So.
Das brauchen wir zwar nicht, aber vielleicht müssen wir uns da später drauf einloggen.
Nochmal. Haben wir eine IP gekriegt?
Ach. Ich seh eine NAT-IP. Da komm ich eh nicht dran.
Hallo. Hast du schon das neue Gnome 40 gesehen?
Das sind drei Wochen...
Ne. Ich bin kein Gnome-Benutzer.
Gnome, äh, könnte mir nicht egaler sein als Desktop-Umgebung.
KDE genauso.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich mag keine...
Keinerlei Linux-Desktop-Umgebung.
Brauch ich ja nicht. Kann ja...
Ich muss ja nicht von anderen vor allem machen.
Ich mag keine Linux-Desktop-Umgebung.
Weder Gnome noch KDE.
Und auch nicht Gnome.
Äh. XFCE.
Pff. Geht irgendwo noch.
Aber find ich auch nicht gut.
Ähm.
Wir können uns gleich mal angucken.
Gnome 40.
Was es da Neues gibt.
Im Zweifelsfall machen die wieder irgendwelche komischen Dinger, die keiner haben will.
Ähm.
Was gibt's denn sonst noch so für Desktop-Gedöns?
Äh.
LXD und sowas.
Ice-WM und so.
Das ist alles nicht mein Fall.
Das einzige, was ich verwende ist...
I3. Und das ist ja kein Desktop.
Das ist im Prinzip noch nicht mal so richtig Windows.
Auch wenn man Windows machen kann, aber...
Äh.
Also Linux-Desktop ist wirklich grausam.
Grausam.
I3 ist noch das, was ich am ehesten aushalte.
Dafür ist I3 echt nice.
So. Also sind wir stehen geblieben.
Wir haben geupdatet.
SSH gestartet.
Disable Auto-Mounting.
Nein. Wurde nicht vorher benutzt.
Meine Disk ist komplett...
...empty.
Guck da. Nix drauf.
20G. Unbenutzt.
Become root. Haben wir schon.
Install ZFS in live CD-Environment.
Alles klar.
Wie gesagt, ich mach copy-paste hero.
Copy-paste einfach nur, was die hier schreiben.
No install. Alles klar.
Excellent. Fertig jetzt eh installiert.
Oh nein!
Wie geht dieses eine Meme nochmal?
Ähm. Moment.
Erstmal kurz überlegen.
Oh no!
Anyway.
Als würde es irgendjemand jucken, gell?
Oh no!
Wird das System dann auch verwendet?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich mach mir das vor allem mal zum ausprobieren.
Ich bin mir am überlegen, ob ich
nicht irgendwas in der Richtung
mache, dass ich mein ganzes...
Dort da, wo ich meine ganzen Containers drauflaufen hab,
dass ich die einfach mal snapshotten kann,
falls ich Upgrade machen will.
Natürlich geht das auch anders.
Aber so ein Snapshot ist manchmal ganz praktisch.
Snapshot, oh Scheiße, kaputt.
Einfach unmounten, Snapshot zurück.
Wobei, wahrscheinlich musst du doch nicht mal unmounten.
Ah, ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
Einfach Docker-Compose down.
Snapshot zurück.
Docker-Compose up ist wieder da.
Das hat schon was dann.
Nutzt du Docker?
Zum größten Teil schon, ja.
Ah, das ist nice.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, auch
bei dieser alten Kiste, wo ich
ZFS drauflaufe, leider mal ausprobiert.
Da hatte ich aber jetzt nicht allzu viel Verwendung
für, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich will ja die einzelnen Container
will ich ja gar nicht snapshotten oder so.
Wenn schon, würde ich die
komplette Disk snapshotten.
Wo das drauf ist.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Habe ich mich noch nicht großartig damit beschäftigt.
Ne, Proxmox mag ich nicht.
Mein Proxmox bringt ja eh nichts
großartig für Container.
Also für Docker-Container.
Du musst dann eine VM machen, in der du Docker-Container
laufen lassen kannst.
Und das kann ich auch so.
Ich habe am liebsten Ubuntu-Server drunter.
So, also was wollen die jetzt hier von mir?
Habe ich das jetzt gemacht? Jawohl.
Installiert.
Modprobe, kernel-Module laden, alles klar.
Backports, ich installiere alles,
was ihr wollt.
So.
Anscheinend war es das jetzt.
Set Variable for Disknet.
Warum?
Ok, ich mache einfach mal richtig
lowbrain die Anleitung.
Einfach nur, wie es da steht.
Sonst geht nachher wieder irgendwas nicht.
def disk
byid, da ist sie.
Alles klar.
Was soll ich jetzt machen? Disk gleich.
Na, meinetwegen.
Wenn die Anleitung das sagt,
dann
machen wir das. Oh nein, ich habe Quotes drum gemacht.
Anzeige ist raus.
Habe ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt?
Ja, ich glaube, habe ich schon fünf Mal oder so.
Nein, nicht meine
Heizungssteuerung.
Habe ich euch schon erzählt,
wie wir zusammen, wie ich letztens
Squidlog-Auswertung
optimiert habe? Von einer Woche auf 15
Minuten runter. Oh was, da steht was
gegen VMware? Oh, MonkaS.
Are you doing this?
Ich benutze kein KVM.
Ach, hier unten, VMware.
Oh, das ist das Falsche.
Guck mal, ich habe meinen CD-ROM.
Ich habe meine CD gerade hinzugefügt
zu Disk.
Ja gut,
fast. Oh nein, da muss ich
neu starten für.
Oh nein.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach
SDA, Alter. SDA
passt schon. Disk.
Ich habe eh nur eine Sache drin,
die kann nur SDA sein.
Ich müsste neu starten, wenn ich
die VMware-Config anpassen will.
Hey, ich mache das jetzt
nicht, ich habe keinen Bock darauf.
Ich meine, Disk gleich
Dev-SDA gut ist.
Und wenn es nicht geht, habe ich halt
gelitten.
Es gibt ja gar nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, was das
werden kann, außer SDA. Ich habe ja sonst nichts dran.
Dronax, 5 Monate, danke schon
für den Sub. So, also
weiter. If you're using, reusing
Disk, nein. Nein, mache
ich nicht. Clear Partition
Table.
Okay, ist eh nichts drauf, aber
oh no.
Partition your
Disks. Also, was macht der da?
Was machen die da für Dinge? Das hat mich das letzte
Mal auch verwirrt. Vielleicht war irgendjemand damals
bei dem Stream noch dabei, schon dabei.
Das hat mich, das kann mich dran erinnern, das hat mich das letzte Mal
auch verwirrt. Da habe ich mich gefragt, was machen
die hier eigentlich? Das sind irgendwelche IDs
oder so, ne?
Also.
Ich habe legit keinen
Plastenschimmer, was das macht. Ich mache
das jetzt einfach. Das macht irgendwie
irgendwelche Partitionen. Das macht
512 MB. Okay, das ist
startet. Das ist quasi
von, vom Start
und dann, und dann irgendwie 512
MB groß.
F00, das ist wahrscheinlich die Partition
ID, denke ich mal.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Keine Ahnung.
Bam. Neko CS 13
Monate. Das ist ja
schon Massive Hyper Subscription.
Wo habe ich
das die Mode? Ich finde es nicht.
Danke für den Sub.
Ah, hier.
Das ist ein Hexcode. Ja, das ist glaube ich die Partitions
ID oder sowas.
So, also jetzt haben wir das, das gemacht.
Ich habe es richtig ausgeführt.
Genau.
Bootpool?
Ah, der macht
Der macht irgendwie
eine Partition für
EFI Boot, eine Partition zum
Booten.
Wo dann ganz Körnelgeschiss und sowas
drauf kommt. Das muss doch
eigentlich gar kein ZFS sein. Das könnte
meinetwegen auch ein XFS
oder so oder ein EXT4 oder irgendwas sein.
Das muss doch, mein Bootpool muss doch
gar kein ZFS sein.
Hat doch eigentlich gar keinen großen Vorteil,
dass das ZFS ist, oder?
Ich mache es jetzt aber mal trotzdem nach der
Anleitung.
Es kann auch FAT16
Kann auch FAT16 sein.
So, wir machen an der Stelle schon mal einen Snapshot,
weil ich weiß, dass ich jetzt gleich irgendwas
verkacken werde bestimmt. Und ich keinen Bock habe, wieder von vorne
anzufangen. So,
jetzt haben wir das erstellt. Choose one
of the following. Unencrypted
oder Native Encryption.
Jap.
Japcock. Weiter.
Okay,
jetzt haben wir alles erstellt. Fdisc
minus L. Wir haben eine Partition
zum EFI Booten.
Warum haben wir eigentlich 2, 3, 4
und nicht 1, 2, 3?
Na gut.
Also, wir haben einen Boot. Wir haben einen EFI.
Weil die hier bei 2
anfangen.
Warum fangen die bei EFI Boot
bei 2 an und bei Legacy Boot bei 1?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube denen einfach, dass das so sein muss.
Jap. Jap habe nur ich
enabled. Jap gibt es nicht für den Chat.
So, ähm.
Oh,
jetzt wird es LFL. Alter.
Mehr
Optionen, please.
Hoho.
Was ist mit denen
los?
Hole birth. Meine Güte.
Klingt aber unanständig.
Was machen wir jetzt?
So, äh. Ja.
Passt so. Lassen wir mal.
Dann createn wir mal den Bootpool.
Ich habe keine Ahnung
was das macht.
Wir machen es einfach.
Das liegt daran, weil ich den Kram...
Das ist kein Ding.
Disc. Def.
SDA3.
Easy geht auch so.
Zack. So.
You should not need to customize any
options. Blablabla.
If you are creating mirror.
Nein. Wir machen
kein Mirror. Wir machen auch kein Raid.
Oder irgendwas, wenn damit einfach
eine Platte und gut ist.
Ja.
Das System
wurde geholeburst.
Die Optionen hören sich
teilweise schon echt kryptisch
an, ne. So.
Okay. Create Rootpool.
Ich erinnere mich.
A Shift 12.
Das macht man glaube ich, weil die Platten
aktuell 4K Sektoren haben
oder sowas.
ZFS ist manchmal ein bisschen kryptisch. Okay.
Native Encryption.
Äh. Partition 4.
Def. SDA4.
Also.
Was machen wir für Optionen?
Encryption.
Key Format Path Phrase.
Wo kann ich denn mein Passwort
jetzt angeben? Wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt gleich eine Passwort
Abfrage, hä? Ah ja. Passwort.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
6.
He doesn't know.
ZFS lacks critical information.
1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Huge Passwort.
Nice. Hat funktioniert.
Äh. Zpool
List. ZFS List.
Was war das richtige?
Das da war das richtige.
Also wir haben ein Bootpool und ein Rootpool.
Das würde ich glaube ich
nicht so machen, wenn ich das
so verwende. Ich würde glaube ich kein Bootpool
erstellen. Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich einfach
das Boot auf ein ZFS äh.
Auf ein X4 oder so machen.
Ich mein wozu? Oder braucht man
das wegen Encryption?
Ne. Kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Na gut.
Machen wir mal weiter.
Das haben wir alles gemacht.
System Installation. Create
File System
Datasets to act as Containers.
Airpool Root.
Airpool Boot.
Alles klar.
Warum nicht, warum nicht
Brut? So.
Jaja was auf Solaris ist es mir wurscht.
Create File System Datasets for
Root and Boot File System.
Mach das jetzt einfach
mal.
Einfach mal braindead durch.
ZFS Mount.
Okay bis jetzt funktioniert alles noch.
Create Data.
Was macht die denn da?
Die kann doch gar nicht so viele Sachen haben.
Gib mir ein Ding für alles und gut
ist kein Home. Wer braucht denn
sowas? Kann ich nicht einfach
ein für alle Mount Points
erstellen? Wobei ich muss doch
eigentlich gar keine Mount
Points erstellen oder? Das passt
doch eigentlich.
Was Status? Ne.
List.
Das reicht doch jetzt eigentlich.
Mehr muss ich doch
eigentlich gar nicht machen. Jetzt schreibt der alles
auf Slash drauf.
Leute nochmal kurz ein Snapshot machen.
Falls es jetzt nicht geht.
Den ganzen anderen Crap
brauche ich überhaupt nicht. Scheiß drauf, dass
es das laut denen ihrer
Moment wird es
überstehen geblieben.
Wo waren wir?
Ja.
Dann snapshotest du auch temporäre Dateien.
Jaja aber das ist mir jetzt gerade vollkommen egal.
Aber das kann man dann später
machen, wenn man das mal ordentlich betreiben will.
Genau. Snapshot auf Cache
für die Packages.
Ausschalten für Temp
ausschalten und sowas.
Klingt ja eigentlich ganz sinnvoll
aber brauchen wir doch nicht.
Aber das muss man. Ne Moment.
Das muss man auch nicht machen.
Aktuell ist alles angelegt.
Passt. Wir gucken einfach mal ob es
funktioniert. Wir benutzen kein
Op. Wir benutzen kein SAV.
Wir benutzen kein UserLockout.
Ich wissentlich.
Snap. Gehst du fort.
Nein.
Kein Gnome.
Wissen wir was?
Es wird Docker benutzen
der sich seine eigenen Datasets
und Snapshots handelt.
Wissen sie was? Das mach ich jetzt einfach mal.
Einfach mal ausgucken was da so
geht.
Parent not present.
Achso weil ich das obere dann
mache ich Scheiß drauf.
Ich lass das jetzt einfach.
Mount TempFS at run.
Ok.
ich weiß nicht so genau was ich mache aber mkd alles klar but if you want separate data set
von temp9 will ich nicht install minimal system ok debian installation auf geht's installier mal
debian snap ist doof ja snap suckt zu snap kann ich bloß sagen also snap ist so die weiß nicht
so eine südafrikanische erfindung ist es ja wirklich um mit snap doof snap ist doof weiß
nicht mag so als aber debian installiert ok copy z pool cash alles klar keine ahnung was es tut
replays hostname mit desired hostname chat
editieren da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran
erinnern dass an den kram den ich hier schon mal dass das schon mal gemacht habe wartet mal kurz
ernsthaft so meint ach so ich soll braucht nur 1 0 w was zum online es ist ein es ist ein nackiger
wim ah please lasst mich in ruhe
ich bin wieder raus, use nano if you find wim confusing ich finde wim nicht confusing
vi ohne alles finde ich tatsächlich confusing configure network interface alles klar name ens33
auto ich werde kein nano verwenden chat so auto ens33 warum geht nicht mal 10
EW, Alter, was ist das denn?
Äh...
ENS 33.
Hier passt.
Das ist ja eine Sache, die finde ich an Debian nice.
Ubuntu
macht ja diese komische Netplan-Geschichte
mit YAML-Dateien.
Da ist mir diese
Konfiguration deutlich lieber.
Ich hatte
auch mal das O'Reilly-Buch
für Wim
2007 oder so. Das war gar nicht so übel,
um das zu lernen.
Aber in der heutigen Zeit
irgendwelche komischen Bücher
null. Ich meine,
Internet, Google, gut ist.
Okay, Configure Package
Store. Nochmal. Ach ne, jetzt wird
das eigentlich das System. Okay.
Weißt du was?
Ähm.
So. Nein, nein, Wim, wie I
ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel des Guten.
Also, das brauchen wir da jetzt alles. Okay.
Wenn die das sagen...
Äh, hallo?
What the...
Ihh!
Da ist Maus-Mode an. Deswegen geht
das nicht. Wer hat denn
Default-mäßig Maus-Modus an?
Äh.
Okay.
Add.
Zack.
Hab ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen?
Sagt mir Bescheid, Chat, wenn ich irgendwas übersehe. Was?
MNT-Abt...
Boah, das ist ja huge-kryptisch.
Keine Ahnung, was das macht, aber wir machen
das jetzt einfach. Alles klar.
Oh ne, Maus-Mode
ist wieder aktiviert. Zack.
Stimmt das jetzt, was der hier kopiert hat?
Ja, tatsächlich. Achso, das ist mit
Zeilenumbruch hier drin.
Package. Äh, das ist
irgendein...
Abt-Magic.
Ist das das, der die Pakete nicht
updatet oder sowas?
Ey, das würde ich nie,
das würde ich so nie auf meinem Server
installieren. Weiß ich in einem halben Jahr nicht mal,
wie es funktioniert. Okay.
Oh, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt
Big-Brain-Magic. Okay.
Also.
Bind.
Dev.
Prog.
Sys.
Temp.
MkT...
Das haben wir doch vorhin schon gemacht.
Nö, jetzt wieder weg.
Was ist genau die Anleitung?
Wie man ein Debian auf dem
ZFS installiert
und davon bootet,
inklusive die native Verschlüsselung von
ZFS verwendet.
Äh, Moment. Disk ist...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
F-S-D-A.
Zack.
Sind wir reingewechselt in das...
zu unser zukünftiges System.
So.
Config a basic system environment.
Alles klar.
Updaten.
Okay.
Das ist aber echt die Hardcore-Manuell-Variante
hier.
If you prefer non-English system language. Nein.
Ich will nur, please,
keine englische Tastatur.
Aber German.
German, no dead keys.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Einfach nur German, no dead keys.
Ja, UTF-8, alles wunderbar.
Excellent.
Okay, hat wahrscheinlich funktioniert.
Install ZFS.
Ach ja, jetzt muss ich das nochmal
installieren, dass es
das ganze ZFS Zeug hat,
wenn ich reboote.
Das vorhin war ja nur auf der Live-CD.
Äh, Uwe Kubikmeter,
das ist irgendeine...
äh...
80 Minuten Nostal...
Nostal...
Nostalgik...
Nostalgik?
Nintendo Wii Games Music Mix.
Düdüdü...
Oje, Leute, ich muss mal ganz kurz...
Ich muss mal kurz weg.
Ich habe aus irgendwelchen Gründen es geschafft,
äh...
Kabel kaputt zu machen.
Das hier war kaputt.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Ganz schön fragile Netzwerkkabel, sage ich euch.
Das ist das zweite Netzwerkkabel, was ich aus dieser...
aus dieser... äh...
Packung habe und das zweite Netzwerkkabel ist kaputt.
Normalerweise gehen Netzwerkkabel nicht kaputt.
Also ich habe vielleicht...
seit ich das mache,
vielleicht, wenn es hochkommt,
eine Handvoll kaputter Netzwerkkabel gesehen.
Aber jetzt sind schon zwei Netzwerkkabel
kaputt gegangen hier beim Umbau.
Das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Es ist ja auch nicht so, als hätte ich die jetzt irgendwie...
geknickt und wäre dann drauf rumgesprungen
oder so.
Ja genau, die Clips brechen ab, aber das Kabel geht nicht.
Das Kabel ist kaputt.
Und lustigerweise, genau dieses Kabel
habe ich letztens noch verwendet.
Hier am Rechner.
Also irgendwas stimmt da nicht.
Echt, echt richtig fragile Kabel.
Ja.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Haben wir das hier schon gemacht?
Ne.
Das da. Nice.
Oh. Anyway.
Alles klar.
Nächste Copy-Pasten.
Also Leute, falls ihr denkt, ich weiß, was ich mache.
Das ist falsch.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was ich mache.
Ich kopiere Anleitungen.
Habe ich im Chat was übersehen, seit ich weg war?
Ubuntu kannst.
Jaja, ich weiß. Debian nicht.
Was war nochmal der Grund,
warum ich es auf Debian ausprobieren wollte?
Nicht auf Ubuntu.
Genau, weil es eine ordentliche Anleitung gab
für Debian Minimalsystem.
Mit Encryption
und auf Root.
Lustigerweise, bei Ubuntu ist der Server-Installer
hat kein ZFS.
Im Desktop-Installer ist es irgendwie experimental.
Und Encryption kann man glaube ich gar nicht
einschalten über den Installer.
Bisschen halbherzig.
Was ich lustig finde, wie gesagt, ich habe ja schon mal
einen Stream gemacht, wo wir ZFS Encryption
eingerichtet haben.
Das ist 3 Jahre her, über 3 Jahre.
Und das Zeug kommt jetzt erst so langsam
aber sicher
in die Distros rein.
Also da malen
die Mühlen teilweise echt langsam.
Ich mag Ubuntu Server.
Einzige, also es gibt eigentlich nur eine Sache,
die mir richtig massiv
auf den Sack geht.
Bei Ubuntu ist
die Geschichte mit Netplan.
Also Netplan ist wirklich
Crap. Das wird weder noch,
das wird nach vm, die wird danach wieder gelöscht.
Also,
jetzt machen wir das, was auch immer uns das
sagt.
Also irgendwie Module neu
beim
Gedöns erstellen, vermute ich mal.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
3 Monate
habe ich schon für den Sub.
Excellent Subscription.
Wobei, das ist noch nicht Hyper Subscriber.
Hyper Subscriber ist nach 12 Monaten.
Excellent Subscription.
Es wird übrigens mal Zeit,
dass ich ein paar Badges mache.
Oder machen lasse, je nachdem.
Ich meine, jetzt haben wir schon ein paar Emotes.
Die Hälfte aller Emote Slots
voll.
Wenn überhaupt, wie viele Emotes habe ich denn?
1, 2, 3, 4
11, 12.
Ja, die Hälfte ungefähr
der Emote Slots ist knapp die Hälfte
voll.
Hyper Subscriber erschlichen, ja.
Bann ist raus direkt.
Bam. Er subscribt, dann gebannt.
Ey Leute, hat jemand eine Ahnung,
was ist, wenn man subscribt und direkt gebannt
wird? Kriegt man dann, kriegt man
das dann erstattet?
Weil es wäre ja schon fies.
Können wir eine Wette machen?
Ja, muss ich mir was überlegen.
Kriegt man nicht?
Moment, was machen wir? Das müssen wir gar nicht machen hier.
Install Crap.
Okay, jetzt wird es ernst.
Install Crap UEFI
Booting.
DOS FS Tools. Alles klar, machen wir.
Ich wollte gucken,
dass ich nichts übersehen habe.
Sieht gut aus, sieht gut aus.
MK DOS FS.
Was?
Auch immer.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Def SDA 2
ist das Richtige.
Wir machen irgendwelche
EFI Verzeichnisse, dass er dann gleich booten kann.
Oh ne, jetzt muss ich
das wieder anpassen.
Siehste, jetzt hätte ich das mal ordentlich gemacht.
Def
SDA 2
So, und jetzt
nach in die
FS Tab schreiben.
Okay.
Hat funktioniert.
Gucken wir mal, was da drin steht.
FS Tab.
Hat echt funktioniert.
Siehste,
dann ist alles gut.
Die UID ändert sich
hoffentlich auch nicht.
Deswegen ist es ja eine UID.
So, also jetzt haben wir den Crap installiert.
Ich mache jetzt nochmal einen
Snapshot, weil es kann immer nochmal schief gehen.
Take Snapshot.
Muss ich danach übrigens alles wieder löschen.
Ich hab immer allzu viel Plattenplatz. Guckt euch das mal an hier.
Ich bin am Limit, Leute. Am Limit.
Wird knapp.
10G
auf C.
Warum habe ich noch 10G auf C?
Wait.
Ich hab jetzt doch alles auf E.
Oder gehen Snapshots immer auf
auf C?
Hoffe ja nicht.
Äh, was bei meinem Arbeitgeber
bis vor kurzem noch extrem viele.
Vor allem mit Suse.
Wow.
Suse mag ich überhaupt
nicht.
Also Suse gefällt mir
wirklich gar nicht.
Das soll ich mounten und jetzt soll ich
Grub installieren.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Remove OS Prober.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Set root Password.
Ja klar. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Alles klar.
Aber das hat doch gar kein Grub installiert.
Oder hat das hier Grub mit installiert?
Ach so, ja. Grub installiert.
Aber wir haben es noch nicht auf die Platte geschrieben.
So.
Enabling importing Bpool.
Ah ja.
Okay.
Nicht, dass ich genau durchblicken würde,
was es da tut.
Aber wir machen das jetzt einfach mal.
Zipper.
Ja, bei Suse ist es Zipper.
Und Yast.
Wobei die Sache ist halt,
die Yast war mal cool vor 20 Jahren.
Mittlerweile ist es irgend so ein
verkorkstes Ding.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, was macht das Unit File?
Gedöns importieren.
Alles klar.
Optional.
Mount a tempfs to temp.
Alles klar.
Mach ich.
User Share System D.
Jetzt machen wir das einfach mal.
Install Popcon?
Nein.
Grub installation. Okay.
Verify that ZFS boot file system is recognized.
Grub brought boop.
Äh, nicht boop. Boot.
Refresh Unit Files.
Ja, mal gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Äh, Kelmore, das geht aber, glaube ich,
an und bei allem, oder?
Dieses Live Kernel Update.
Das ist auch nicht, ähm,
nicht hundertprozentig.
Das hat Eigenheiten,
was nicht geht.
Das geht nur in speziellen Fällen.
So, er hat ein Boot Image erstellt.
Okay, passt.
Workaround.
Grubs Missing Zpool Feature Support.
Äh.
Was, was wollen die von mir?
Das ist doch auskommentiert.
Das, das, das
checke ich jetzt nicht.
Was wollen die von mir?
Ich meine, wenn ich das auskommentiert da rein schreibe,
wird der wohl kaum was bringen.
Hä?
Okay.
Also, so.
Das hätte man auch ein bisschen schöner schreiben können.
Okay.
Make Debugging Grub Easier.
Remove Quiet.
Das habe ich schon entfernt.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Sucked. Brauchen wir nicht.
Uncomment Grub Terminal.
Ups.
Habe ich.
Okay.
Update Grub Configuration.
Alles klar.
Raus die Musik. Fertig.
Ups.
Excellent. Nochmal neu starten.
So.
Alles funktioniert.
Update Grub. Haben wir gemacht.
Oder haben wir es gemacht?
Wir machen es einfach nochmal.
So. Install Bootloader. Legacy BIOS. Machen wir nicht.
Install UEFI Bootloader.
Bam.
Grub install x86
efi boot efi bootloader
debian
Oh. Schwierige Entscheidung.
So floppy wäre schon nicht schlecht.
Okay. No error reported.
Sehr gut.
Fix file system mounting order.
Meine Güte ey.
Das ist ja eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Separate mount points.
Ich mache einfach was die Typen mir vorschlagen.
So.
Getouched. Alles klar.
Oh nein.
File exist.
Okay. Ist das jetzt schlecht?
Ich weiß eh nicht was das macht wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Und macht das jetzt was?
Guck mal mal was es macht.
Es macht Dinger.
Okay. Der scheiß Gnorm.
Ach man muss das im Background machen.
Das wird gar nicht fertig oder was?
Ach so.
Boah das ist echt big brain hier.
Das ist echt big brain hier.
Ah not empty.
Not empty.
Auch not empty.
Okay. Also passt alles.
Hat alles funktioniert.
Fix the path.
Ich copy paste da einfach nur noch.
Alles gut.
Okay. Install OpenSSH auf jeden Fall.
Das Syslink was gefailt ist.
Ja das ist eine gute Idee.
Also.
Ach so. Moment hier.
Wie ist das hier?
History.
Zeit of user.
Ich würde sagen das passt.
Sieht eigentlich gut aus.
So. Permit root login.
Yes.
Snapshot installation.
Ne. Exit.
Okay. Ich glaube es wird ernst.
Ich glaube es wird ernst.
Run these commands.
Zum unmounten. Okay machen wir.
Alles klar. Reboot.
Ohhhh.
Okay.
Bam. Mal gucken.
Und.
Und. Und.
Ohhhh.
Enter passphrase.
12345678.
Das funktioniert.
Poc.
Root. 123456.
Bam. Da sind wir am Start. Easy.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Easy.
Okay. So. Jetzt gehen wir mal auf ein anderes System.
65. Achso. Moment.
Wir müssen mal kurz die Netzwerkkarte umstöpseln.
Das ich eine ordentliche IP kriege.
Bridged.
Rebooten.
Connect.
Ey. Ey.
Connected.
Das hat sich gerade wieder ausgeschaltet.
Was soll das?
Okay. 12345678.
Gutenberg wäre stolz.
Du meinst weil ich so gut kopiert habe.
Ja. Nice.
Das musste ich mir merken. Der ist gut.
Wenn einer ordentlich Copy-Paste.
Dann sage ich jetzt auch Gutenberg wäre stolz.
Das hat was.
2128.
Achso. Root.
Root tut gut.
123456.
Zack. Update.
Sind wir am Start.
So. Dann kopieren wir mal die Anleitung nochmal rüber.
Okay.
Wait.
Da.
Und mache noch die restlichen Schritte. Irgendwas fehlt da bestimmt noch.
Morgen nehme ich das Video auf
mit dem Shit-Repo Azumi.
Hab mir schon überlegt.
Okay.
First boot sind wir jetzt.
Haben wir gemacht. Haben wir gemacht.
Eingeloggt. Reboot.
Create a user account.
Die machen das alles als Root.
Warum soll ich einen neuen User anlegen?
Lull.
Er braucht denn schon was anderes als Root-User.
Also mal ernsthaft jetzt.
Overrated.
Einfach alles als Root machen.
Nie wieder rechte Probleme haben.
Das machen wir nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Configure Swap.
Ja Chrome mag auch nicht laufen.
Auf
Root.
Da muss man die Sendbox ausschalten.
Vincent Hanna.
Mit Prime.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
IQ++ für den Chat hier.
Platz gleich.
So.
Also das machen wir nicht.
Swap brauchen wir nicht.
Immerhin.
4G muss reichen.
Full Software Installation.
Okay.
Upgrade to Minimal System.
Jaja.
Debian Minimal System ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Ja gut.
Wir haben ja schon SSH installiert.
Brauchen wir ja eigentlich nichts.
SSH Server ist schon drauf.
Und jetzt ist eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Äh.
Na gut.
Wir müssen das wieder löschen.
In der Hoffnung wird meine Festplatte ein bisschen mehr frei.
Hab ich noch 10,5?
Warum ist das so groß auf einmal?
Moment.
Falsche VM.
Snapshot Manager.
Oh.
Das wusste ich auch nicht, dass das geht.
Man kann 3 Snapshots auf einmal löschen.
Poggers.
Geht 3 Stunden später.
Leute hat jemand von euch Tasmota auf einer Steckdose installiert?
Und hat mit der
9.3 auch Probleme,
dass es Massive langsam ist.
Das Web Interface nach dem Update.
Okay.
Jetzt kommen wieder die Normalos.
Die sagen wie?
Was habe ich installiert auf meiner Steckdose?
Keckweight?
Ja aber ich meine das ernsthaft.
Was auf der Steckdose installiert?
Und seit 9.3?
Kam
vorgestern raus oder so?
Ja Leute.
Ich sehe es genauso wie du.
Leute die ihre Steckdose nicht flashen.
Normies.
Reeeeee.
Ja.
Da kam nämlich gestern.
Gestern oder vorgestern.
Es ist ganz neu.
7 Ok vor 7 Tagen.
Version 9.3.
Und angeblich ist da irgendwie
ein bisschen verbesserte Home Assistant Support
oder irgendwas dabei habe ich gelesen.
Deswegen wollte ich es updaten.
Ultra langsam bei der einen Steckdose.
Es ist auch die einzige mit der ich es ausprobiert habe.
Wo ist denn die überhaupt?
Wo habe ich denn die hin?
Keckweight?
Wo sind die?
Ist das die die hier steht?
Moment.
Ich muss die irgendwo hin haben.
Ich hatte die vorhin in der Hand.
Verwirrungsstelz.
Warte mal ich habe die bestimmt in meinem Serverraum hinten gelegt.
Warte mal.
Ich wollte die jetzt eigentlich nur mal schnell anstöpseln.
Ob die jetzt geht.
Wo habe ich denn die hin?
Ist die das doch hier?
Ich stöpsel die jetzt hier einfach mal dran.
Und hoffe dass die das ist.
Die Steckdose ist weiß.
Und steckt in der anderen weißen Steckdose.
Deswegen habe ich die nicht gesehen.
Die war die ganze Zeit dran schon.
Gucken wir mal.
Mal gucken ob das Tasmota Zeug sich jetzt wieder gefangen hat.
60.108
Hat die glaube ich gekriegt.
Näää.
Danke für den Sub.
Ah doch da ist er.
Aber die hat die Settings wieder vergessen.
Die hat die Settings vergessen.
Guck mal das Web Interface ist übelst lahm geworden.
Lullup96
Danke für den Sub.
Guck mal seht ihr das.
Wie kacke lahm das Web Interface ist.
Voll im Arsch.
Seit dem Update die Steckdose.
Ey ich habe für die wichtigen Sachen.
DNS bei mir am Start.
Diese Steckdosen.
Die steuere ich eh über mein Home Assistant.
Da brauche ich keine DNS Aliasse.
Weil da heißen die Geräte halt.
Arbeitszimmer Schreibtisch oder so.
Guck mal was ist denn mit dem Web Interface los.
Das kann doch nicht in den Ernst sein.
Hier seht ihr das.
Kacke wait.
Und außerdem hat das irgendwie die.
Jetzt hat er reloadet.
Habt ihr das gesehen wie lange das gedauert hat.
Guck euch das mal an.
Das Web Interface von meiner Steckdose ist langsam.
Ey er ist aber so.
So und die Settings hat er sich auch nicht gemerkt.
Ja das ist die Steckdose.
Das da.
Normalerweise.
Muss man das hier rein kopieren.
Guck mal der lädt immer noch.
Was ist das denn.
Guck euch das mal an wie lahm das ist.
Magst du auf Twitch.
Aber ich habs nie so selten an die große Glocke gehängt.
Guck mal das lädt einfach nicht.
Massive massive lahm.
Ja ja ferngesteuerte Steckdose.
Smarte Steckdosen.
Zum Beispiel ein Anwendungszweck wofür das richtig cool ist.
Du siehst hier meinen 3D Drucker.
Und ich kann den automatisch ausschalten lassen wenn der Druck zu Ende ist.
Das ist praktisch.
Der Scheiß braucht ordentlich Strom.
Druck zu Ende.
Warte ich noch 5 Minuten nachdem der Timer aus ist.
Schalte ich ihn automatisch aus über die Steckdose.
Also dafür wollte ich die Steckdose.
Guck mal die lädt immer noch.
Seit ich geupdatet habe auf 9.3 ist das Ding absolut unusable.
Ist doch der Witz.
Ja und wenn man pingt witzigerweise.
Ist kein Problem.
Funkt.
Oh.
Schwankt ein bisschen.
Macht die alte Firmware doch wieder drauf.
Ja wenn ich mal überhaupt bis dahin kommen würde.
Dann könnte ich das machen.
Kannst du voll.
Vergessen.
Äh.
Shriker das ist.
Das falsche.
Nein nein da geht kein SSH.
Da ist ja kein Lilungs drauf.
Wann kommt der Weihnachts Kekwe wieder weg?
Also ich würde sagen an Weihnachten.
Weil ich das ehrlich gesagt ziemlich cool finde.
Dass ich als einziger den Weihnachts Kekwe habe.
Oder soll ich den weg machen?
Chat ihr könnt es euch aussuchen.
Ich finde den cool dass der Weihnachts Kekwe noch da ist.
Also wie ihr wollt.
Wir machen eine Umfrage.
Welches Kekwe.
Ne wir machen eine Umfrage.
Soll.
Soll der.
Weihnachten.
Kekwe weg.
Und wieder.
Der normale hin.
Ja.
Nein.
Dauert zwei Minuten.
Weg.
Oder bleiben.
Anzeichen.
Behalten.
Alten Kekwe.
Normalen Kekwe.
Wieder rein machen.
Umfrage beginnen.
So.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich bin auch dafür den zu behalten.
Der Chat auch. Sehr schön.
Wird hier öfters gestreamt?
Ja guckt doch mal in die History.
Ich war glaub.
Die letzten.
Drei von vier Tagen on.
Oder so.
Es kann sein dass das Wort vom Sonntag nicht da ist.
Weil dann hab ich auf AliExpress.
Aus versehen ein.
Oder es war wirklich aus versehen.
Ich weiß es hört sich jetzt doof an.
Einen ähm.
Besonders lebensnahen Dildo gezeigt.
Aus versehen auf AliExpress.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht ich lösch das mal.
Wer weiß was Twitch dazu sagt.
Das wurde einfach so empfohlen.
Das wurde einfach.
Scheiß ich war bei AliExpress.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ich auf AliExpress gezeigt hab.
Nichts was damit zu tun hatte.
Ich glaub wir haben uns ein Fertighaus.
Auf AliExpress angeguckt.
Fertighaus auf AliExpress.
Auf einmal kommt da unten irgend so ein komischer.
Jepp Kock.
Jepp Kock aus Silikon.
Kam dann auf einmal unten in der Empfehlung.
I need Kock.
Cola.
Kennt ihr noch jemand?
Das sind so Oldschool Meme Videos.
Kennt heute keiner mehr.
Doch klar ok.
Kock.
Please give me Kock.
Cola.
Ok.
Kennt man.
Ehm.
Ja kann man.
Und es gibt sogar ein komplettes.
Security Research Projekt.
Was sich mit Exploits von.
Sex Tools.
Toys nicht Tools.
Beschäftigt.
Und es gibt sogar ein Open Source Projekt.
Es gibt sogar ein Open Source Projekt.
Für.
Ehm.
Den.
Open Source Buttplug.
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen.
Wie dieses Projekt heißt.
Das hat einen richtig geilen Namen.
So richtig.
Wo nur irgendwelche.
Hacker Leute drauf kommen können.
69.
Jawoll.
Weihnachtskäckweh bleibt Leute.
Alles klar Weihnachtskäckweh.
Easy.
Moment ich muss mal kurz gucken wie das hieß.
Heise.
Bei Heise stand das irgendwie.
Ach keine Ahnung.
Ist auch egal wie das Ding heißt.
Genau buttplug.io war das eine.
Ne es gab irgendwie so ein Security Projekt.
Es hat einen richtig geilen Namen.
Aber allein schon das es sowas gibt.
Und ja man kann das flashen.
Man kann das flashen.
Ist doch nicht normal.
Okay ich downgrade jetzt einfach.
Releases.
Wo ist das alte.
By the way.
Das hat mit ZFS gar nichts zu tun.
Wo man.
Nur so.
Fällt mir nur gerade so ein.
Das ich meine Steckdose mal wieder flashen muss.
Tasmota.
Ich weiß nicht.
Bin.
Minimal.
Muss man downloaden.
So wir flashen das.
Ich flashe das jetzt schnell das meine Steckdose wieder geht.
Tasmota minimal flashen.
Upgrade.
Zerstört Max mit dem downgrade seine Steckdose.
Ne das müssen wir nicht wetten.
Die geht nicht kaputt.
Weil wenn die kaputt gehen würde müsste ich sie aufschreiben.
Aufschrauben.
Und ich kann die nicht mehr aufschrauben.
Weil ich habe die mit Heißkleber wieder zu gemacht.
Also wenn ich die jetzt pricke.
Doch wetten please.
Ok wie wettet man denn.
Jetzt müsst ihr mir sagen.
Ich weiß nicht wie das geht.
Noch kann da nichts passieren.
Noch ist die Minimal Firmware.
Umfrage.
Ne konnte man nicht.
Twitch bet points.
Moment wie wettet man Punkte.
Predictions.
Juhu.
Ich will doch nicht von Juhu mir beibringen lassen.
Ok Leute.
Wie geht das.
Mod check.
Ich brauche help.
Ich weiß nicht wie das geht.
Slash bet.
Ne.
Ok.
Das geht nicht.
Das muss man.
Und 3D.
Das muss man einrichten.
Für Streamer.
Jaja.
Umfrage.
Wetten.
Ok Leute ich habe keine Ahnung wie das geht.
Ich habe legit.
Eine Umfrage vorschlagen kann man machen.
Ok Twitch.
Vorhersage.
Ok also zeig her Twitch.
Wie geht das.
Wie starte ich eine Vorhersage.
Creator Mods die in den.
Prediction.
Slash Prediction.
Ah.
Ok ich gebe euch 2 Minuten Zeit.
Dann mache ich jetzt das Update.
Dann sehen wir ob es geprickt wird.
Wobei ne.
Eine Minute.
Also Umfrage benennen.
Macht Max mit dem Downcrate.
Seine Steckdose kaputt.
Fragezeichen.
Ergebnis ja.
Ergebnis nein.
Vorhersage starten.
Oh ich habe zu viel.
Macht das Downcrate.
Steckdose kaputt.
Fragezeichen.
Vorhersage starten.
Vorhersage bestätigen.
Du oder ein Mod musst das Ergebnis innerhalb von 24 Stunden.
Nach dem Ende der Einrichtungsfrist.
Der Vorhersage bestätigen.
Ok verstanden.
Übrigens Glücksspiel kann süchtig machen.
Erst ab 18.
Disclaimer.
Mal auf die Schnelle.
Ok.
Wie ich sehe nicht.
Ich sehe nicht.
Wie viel zu wie viel es steht.
Alter.
Was habt ihr alles für Channel Points.
Ok das muss nein sein.
Du musst auf predict klicken.
Ne ne.
Ich sehe es ja immer noch bei mir.
So.
Und wie.
Und wie bestätige ich das jetzt.
Die ist jetzt weg.
Leute habt ihr die Channel Points wieder bekommen.
Die ist weg die Umfrage.
Moment.
Woher weiß ich denn jetzt ob die.
Fuck wo hatte ich denn jetzt hier gerade die Sache mit dem.
Mit dem Twitch.
Start Prediction.
Ah.
Ok also Moment.
Ich muss mir das jetzt erstmal angucken wie das funktioniert.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Dashboard.
Ach du siehst die jetzt.
Das heißt die Mods können das auch.
Äh Captain Peng.
Kannst du mal bei dir im Dashboard gucken ob du das jetzt.
Bestätigen kannst dann.
Ok ok ich downgrade jetzt erstmal.
Also.
Ich habe jetzt also was ich jetzt gemacht habe ich folgendes.
Ich habe auf 9.3.
Minimalfirmware.
Umgestellt.
Das ist.
Kein Problem das geht eigentlich immer.
Auf Minimalfirmware umstellen.
Das Problem ist das downgrade.
Auf eine Version.
Und der Typ schreibt sogar.
Das hätte ich vielleicht vorher sagen sollen.
Ich glaube der Typ schreibt sogar.
Das ab dieser Version downgrades nicht mehr supported werden.
Guck.
Also.
Also schauen wir mal.
Ähm.
Dann uploaden wir jetzt.
Wir haben jetzt 9.1.
Tasmota bin.
Komm wir downloaden das.
GG Zipte.
Upgrade starten.
Ok.
Also auf gehts.
Probieren wir mal.
Also wohlgemerkt geprickt.
Also.
Booten denke ich wird es auf jeden Fall.
Es zählt erst als erfolgreich.
Wenn es bootet.
Und ordentlich funktioniert.
Also.
Wenn ich dann auch was mit machen kann.
Also wenn die danach nicht mehr schaltet.
Dann ist die geprickt.
Auch wenn sie bootet.
Ok start upgrade.
Ok successful.
Schonmal gut.
Das heißt noch gar nichts.
Da ist sie wieder.
Es geht nicht.
Also.
Kann das Ding auch Strom messen?
Die nicht.
Ähm. Aber die anderen die ich hab.
Moment.
Warum heißt das noch basic module?
Sollte das nicht anders heißen?
Ah device name.
Ähm.
Die anderen gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Ja ja ich muss nochmal restarten.
Äh.
Device name.
Wie habe ich denn das andere Ding genannt?
Beides oder so?
Egal ich speicher jetzt.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach ob es funktioniert.
So also wenn ihr jetzt bootet und jetzt schaltet.
Dann funktioniert es.
Die Vorhersage ist nein.
Ich glaube die Vorhersage ist auch richtig.
Also.
Ja es schaltet.
Klick klick klick klick.
Wir haben es nicht geprickt.
Gewinner.
Nein.
Ich bin froh das es nicht geprickt ist.
Und. Der Kram läuft doch wieder schnell.
9.3 ist das Problem.
Guck mal wie schnell 9.1 läuft.
Habt ihr gesehen wie 9.3 rumgeleckt hat?
Eats 2k verdient ja hier.
Fast besser wie bei Gamestop.
So und jetzt kann ich inzwischen meinen 3D Drucker stöpseln.
Und den 3D Drucker damit an und ausschalten.
So.
Das ist by the way aber überhaupt nicht das wofür wir da sind.
Äh. Eigentlich wollten wir.
Warte mal.
Was mussten wir ZFS mäßig jetzt noch machen?
Final Cleanup.
Haben wir nicht.
Wir haben hier eh nur Root.
Was du hier sollst ganz ohne Channel Points.
Neue Channel Points sammeln.
Was sonst?
Es gibt übrigens ein nices Plugin Leute.
Ähm.
Wie heißt das denn?
Auto Channel Points.
Gibt es nices.
Autoclaim.
Ja ich weiß nicht welches davon ist.
Der macht es für euch automatisch.
Ach echt FFZ kann das mittlerweile auch?
Oh das ist cool.
Wirklich?
Äh.
Nach was muss ich das suchen?
Points?
Kioko 19 Monate. Nice.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das ist natürlich Hyper Subscription.
Highlight Messenger.
Ne hier kann man das nicht machen.
Oder braucht man dafür den extra FFZ Addon?
Ah du musst zu den Addons.
Ok ok.
Smoky Utilities.
Was macht das?
Äh.
Ja ist ja geil.
Was ist denn da?
Ok.
Ich aktiviere das jetzt einfach mal.
Und dann gucken wir mal schnell.
Smoky Enable.
Settings.
Es gibt gar keine Settings dafür.
Jetzt Points.
Ah hier.
Auto Point Claimer.
Oh nice.
Easy.
Solltest du Leute einfach gucken und automatisch Points claimen.
So geht das.
Nice. Easy.
Das brauchen wir.
Ich meine hier disable ich es jetzt wieder.
Weil hier bin ich ja nicht mal eingeloggt.
Easy.
Um nicht zu sagen. Easy.
Wisst ihr was noch?
Weißt ihr was noch mehr Next Level wäre?
Wenn man nicht da ist.
Einfach auf dem Server Twitch mit Headless Chrome laufen lassen.
Geht bestimmt irgendwie.
Und dort dann Auto Claim.
Also 24 7 Channel Points grabben.
Ohne das man guckt.
Bei 100 Streams.
Und dann ist man Channel Point
Milliardär.
So jetzt mal schnell gucken.
Wir sind durch glaube ich mit der Standardsache.
So und jetzt ist die Frage.
Wie schaffe ich das, dass ich
automatisch anlocke.
Install.
Up. Auto. Complete.
Debian.
Das ist erstmal das allerwichtigste.
Wie mache ich Auto Complete und Debian.
Achso einfach nur Bash Completion installieren.
Das ist ja easy.
Der hätte nicht gedacht,
dass es so einfach ist.
Tatsächlich.
Install.
Job.
Also ich versuche jetzt nochmal,
dass man den Kram per SSH anlocken kann.
Aber wahrscheinlich werde ich das nicht hinbekommen.
Ja wir haben gerade gewettet.
Der Crypt Setup brauche ich ja auch nicht.
Ohne das kriege ich dann mal gebacken.
Leute ich muss mal meinen eigenen Stream abgucken.
Ich muss mal meinen eigenen Stream abgucken.
Wie haben wir das das letzte Mal gemacht.
Guck mal hier.
Einfach Stream von vor 3 Jahren angucken.
Da haben wir das nämlich irgendwann schon mal gemacht.
What the f... Max was machst du da?
Hier.
Permit Route.
Okay Max was hast du vor 3 Jahren gemacht?
Ich habe es irgendwie hingekriegt.
Anscheinend.
Ich habe aber am besten keinen Plan mehr.
Wie?
Ey Leute wenn ich es vor 3 Jahren schon hingekriegt habe.
Easy.
Ne nicht mit Zertifikaten.
Mit Passphrase habe ich es vor 3 Jahren hingekriegt.
Ich habe ein extra Skript gebastelt.
Oh ne da bin ich zu müde für jetzt.
Das kriege ich nicht mehr hin.
Okay NFS.
Ja das weiß ich.
Wie es funktioniert.
Was habe ich damals gemacht?
Das ganze System ist verschlüsselt.
Authorize Keys.
Jaja passt schon Max.
Okay kommt jetzt schon eine Abfrage.
Wenn ich neu starte.
Was muss man machen?
Minus K?
Minus U all oder so?
Ach ne K all muss man machen.
Invalid Authorize Keyfile.
E-Mode Unlocking will not work.
Ja das ist mir erstmal wurscht.
Ich will jetzt erstmal gucken ob das prinzipiell da überhaupt reingeht.
Jaja ich weiß wie das funktioniert.
Ich will nur gucken ob da jetzt überhaupt was macht.
Okay da würde den K...
Netboot?
Achso ne da hat es jetzt nur vom DHCP was geholt.
Okay.
Der Server ist gestartet anscheinend.
Gut da muss ich jetzt noch ein
SSH Key reinschmeißen.
Mal gucken wir mal.
Äh wie ging das nochmal?
ETC Init ne äh
Authorize Keys
und da muss ich hier mein
und da muss ich mein SSH Login rein machen.
Äh Cut
SSH
EDRSA
PUP
Max Add Poggers. Ja genau.
So mag ich das.
Da sieht man gleich das muss ein SSH Key von mir sein.
Ich erkenne auf der
Arbeit auch immer sofort meine SSH Keys.
Weil die haben immer so doofe Comments.
Da weiß ich gleich das es meiner ist.
Okay.
Du kannst den Key abschreiben. Das ist ein Public Key.
Der bringt dir gar nichts.
Der aktiviert das Netzwerk das er von irgendwo den Key her bekommt.
Ja normalerweise macht er das auch
komplett automatisch.
Aber ich glaube ZFS können die standardmäßig nicht.
Okay Reboot.
Schauen wir mal ob es
zumindest bis zum Login funktioniert.
Weil extra
Skript basteln wie das letzte mal habe ich kein Bock drauf.
Da bin ich zu müde für.
Okay.
Der startet den Kram.
Äh ja ist gut.
Options No
Strict Host Key Checking
No
Da sind wir.
Cryptroot Unlock.
Ob das funktioniert?
Ne das hätte mich auch gewundert. Das ist.
Geht nur für Lux.
Ja das ganze
ZFS Zeug ist dann.
Was ist das?
ZFS Unlock?
Wait a minute.
Ist das etwa alles schon dabei?
Ich muss gar nichts mehr machen?
Easy.
Das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Okay das ist wirklich easy.
Zack.
Ja nice.
Okay das ist definitiv
einfacher.
Da muss ich mal kurz den Hacker Modus aktivieren.
Ähm.
Das ist definitiv einfacher als
vor 3 Jahren.
Vor 3 Jahren musste ich ja noch ein eigenes Skript zusammenwursten.
Richte Hacker Mode
wieder an hier.
Das ist ja.
Das ist wirklich nicht schwer.
Also hätten die das jetzt bei Ubuntu Server
ordentlich integriert.
Das man beispielsweise das im Installer
auswählen kann. Dann würde ich es verwenden.
Auf diese Zeremonien einen Server
auf root zu installieren habe ich kein Bock.
Genau.
Also ptbear
So wie ich das verstehe.
Hat der
einen SSH Server
in sein Boot Image
reingemacht.
Dann der startet das Netzwerk.
Startet einen SSH Server.
Dann musste ich mich einloggen.
Per Key Authentifizierung.
Weil ich den vorher hinterlegt habe.
Und dort konnte ich dann das Passwort eingeben.
Und nachdem das Passwort eingegeben wurde
hat er das Laufwerk unlogged.
Und dann den Boot weiter eingestoßen.
Wir können ja da mal reingucken was das macht.
Hier ZFS Unlock.
Gucken wir mal rein.
Das ist bestimmt ein normales Shell Skript.
Also nicht mal sonderlich lang.
Das macht der.
Also mit Lux Images
funktioniert das schon lange.
Das benutze ich seit Jahren auf irgendwelchen Servern
oder sonst wo wo das verschlüsselt sein muss.
Mit Lux funktioniert das schon richtig lange.
Ich wusste nicht das mit ZFS auch funktioniert.
Ok. Aber das ist auch gar nicht sonderlich lang.
Dieses Bash Ding.
Was macht denn das?
Bla bla bla.
Ist glaube ich auch ziemlich egal.
Genau.
Er macht eine Schleife.
Solange es nicht unlogged ist.
Dann fragt er
das Passwort ab.
Würde ich mal sagen.
Ach ne das ist das Kommando zum Passwort abführen.
Hier wird das Passwort abgefragt.
Das hier ist der Name vom Filesystem.
Genau. Und er pipet das dann nach
Loadkey. Loadkey ist wahrscheinlich das Ding
zum Entsperren.
Dropbear ist ein minimaler SSH Server.
Der ist schon dabei.
Könnte man Brutforcen.
Wie lang brauchst
denn du
für 1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8
um das zu Brutforcen?
Das kann man ja von Hand Brutforcen.
Was der Hackerman.
1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8 hast du ganz schnell.
So.
Also das ist nice.
Das gefällt mir, dass das so easy funktioniert hat.
Was macht eigentlich der Speicherplatz auf meiner Festplatte?
Oh immer noch.
Warum ist das so klein?
Wartet mal kurz. Download.
Debian Live. Oh.
Ich hab da noch eine Windows ISO drauf.
Keck wait.
Warte mal. Debian weg. Windows ISO weg.
Office 2000.
Warum?
Weil das ist ein Windows XP Stelz den wir mal gemacht haben.
Falls sich noch der ein oder andere erinnert.
Wir haben noch mal
Windows XP Stelz gemacht.
Dafür habe ich das gebraucht.
Windows 2000.
Wenn es.
Die alten Versionen
hiervon brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Können wir alles wieder löschen.
So ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen Platz.
Okay 20G. Bisschen mehr Platz wieder.
Nice.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut.
Also das Install ist noch ein bisschen kompliziert.
Aber ich sag mal so.
Wenn die wirklich
im nächsten.
Also spätestens. Also ich hoffe mal drauf.
Spätestens in der nächsten Ubuntu LTS.
Also sprich.
Das wäre dann.
Nächstes Jahr. April.
Stimmt das?
Ubuntu LTS Schedule.
Off.
Jubantu. Geh off.
All.
Kann nicht drinstehen.
Also es müsste dann.
2204 müsste das nächste.
LTS sein.
Hier.
Jaja.
Genau das nächste.
Also ich hoffe mal das sie es hinbekommen.
Das spätestens bis 2204.
ZFS mit Encryption.
Im Installer drin ist.
Das wäre cool.
Weil ansonsten.
Ist alles nice.
Alles nicht sonderlich schwierig.
Aber.
Auf diese Zeremonie hätte ich kein Bock.
Jedes mal wenn ich ein System installiere.
Diese Zeremonie hier zu machen.
Das ist mir zu doof.
Dann lieber defaultmäßig im Installer.
Es ist im Installer drin.
Aber es ist im Installer nicht für Server.
OS drin.
Und es ist im Installer Experimental.
Und es ist keine Encryption drin.
Also im Prinzip das was ich haben will.
Aber es ist eine coole Sache.
Ok.
Jetzt haben wir den Kram.
Docker macht angeblich eigene ZFS Snapshots.
Stand da irgendwo.
Das probieren wir doch jetzt einfach mal aus.
Docker.
Ist das überhaupt installiert?
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal einen Debian Container.
Debian Container.
Im Debian Container.
Und dann guck ich mal.
Ob das eigene Sachen macht.
Ok.
Docker.
Wie geht denn das?
Debian Bash.
Ne.
Wie ging das nochmal?
Das kriege ich aus dem Kopf immer nicht hin.
Ja.
Dropware ist Poggers.
Docker Run.
Debian Bash.
Ah.
Ich habe es fast richtig.
Ok.
Dann machen wir jetzt Docker Run.
Musste man "-rm machen, dass es danach wieder löscht?
Ach ne. Moment.
Wir sind schon drinnen.
Es hat doch funktioniert.
Lol.
Nice.
Aber Debian in Debian am laufen.
Und nochmal upgraden.
Debian in Debian.
So. Und jetzt gucken wir mal.
Und jetzt hat.
Und jetzt hat das eigene Docker Image
ein eigenes ZFS angelegt.
Ne oder?
Ist das hier?
Sind das hier die Docker Images?
Könnte sein. Ne?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Docker rm.
Ah. Jetzt sind sie weg.
Jetzt ist noch das Image da.
Tatsächlich. Docker macht eigene ZFS Datasets.
Ok.
Docker rmi.
Debian Latest.
Jetzt ist alles weg.
Ok. Und was genau.
Lass mal überlegen.
Was genau bringt mir das jetzt?
Eigentlich.
Will ich das gar nicht?
Ne. So wirklich bringen tut mir das jetzt
eigentlich gar nichts. Wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Was viel cooler wäre.
Wenn ich ein komplettes.
Wenn ich das.
Valib.
Docker.
Wenn ich das komplette Valib Docker auf
ZFS kriegen würde.
Weil das coole wäre.
Dann könnte ich echt ein Docker Compose
File machen.
Und ich würde einfach
einen Snapshot machen.
Von dem kompletten Valib Docker.
Dann würde ich ein
Update machen.
Und wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Also mal angenommen.
Ich hätte ein Docker Compose File.
Wo alles auf Latest steht.
So. Und dann mache ich ein Update.
Und wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Mache ich einfach den Snapshot zurück.
Und es geht wieder.
Das wäre eigentlich cool.
Der Desktop.
Massive POG.
Das ist der Grund warum ich kein
Latest Tag nehme.
Aber man könnte den Latest Tag nehmen.
Und einfach vorher einen Snapshot machen.
Dann würde ich den.
Dann würde ich das nämlich alles
auf eine Platte packen.
Mein Compose File.
Das Docker Zeug.
Und alles. Und dann Snapshot.
Wenn es nicht geht.
Einfach Snapshot zurück.
Vorher Docker Compose Down.
Und dann Snapshot zurück.
POG.
Muss ich mir mal Gedanken drüber machen.
Aber ich bin schon mal begeistert.
Wie nice das funktioniert.
Es ist alles gut integriert.
Bis auf das Setup.
Das Setup sackt ein bisschen.
Aber ansonsten.
Es funktioniert alles out of the box.
Ja genau. Extremtechniker.
So ungefähr habe ich mir das gedacht.
Und jetzt ZFS Unlock.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. Bam. Unlockt.
Lockt mich aus.
Das ist schon cool.
Das ist nice.
Also das funktioniert easy.
Nur das manuelle Setup nervt mich ein bisschen.
Ich muss mir mal Internet von 1995 angucken.
Ah yes.
Netscape now.
Jawoll.
Eine Runde Blizzard von 1995.
Oh.
Sehr nice.
Yes.
So sah Battle.net 1995 aus.
Ich kann mich da noch dran erinnern.
Da sah ich, als ich Battle 1 online gespielt habe.
Mit dem Modem.
Da sah das ungefähr so kacke aus.
Wie es jetzt aussieht.
Die Warcraft 1 Demo.
Nintendo.com
Wie sah Nintendo.com 1996 aus?
Wahrscheinlich genauso wie heute.
Bei Nintendo weiß man nie.
Oh. Oh ne.
RIP.
Nintendo will nicht.
Wikipedia 1996.
Oh es funktioniert irgendwie gerade nichts.
Warum ist denn das so kaputt?
ICQ.
Guck mal die Weebs waren damals schon am Start.
Seht ihr das?
So sah Wikipedia 1996 aus.
Ja.
Sogar 1996 waren sie schon am Start.
Das mach ich jetzt lieber nett auf.
Sonst kommen noch irgendwelche Tentakel oder so.
Das ist nicht kaputt.
Das hat so lange gedauert.
Ach du meinst das ist die Original Experience.
Das hat ja auch das Laden simuliert.
Übrigens damals war es normal,
dass die Seiten weiß waren.
Darkseam hat da keiner dran gedacht.
Aber ich kann es mal machen,
dass ihr nicht blind werdet.
Darkseam.
Ich weiß gar nicht ob man damals überhaupt
Background setzen konnte
in HTML schon.
Oh ja.
Download den Internet Explorer.
Unbedingt.
Endlich.
Guck mal die finale Version
für den Internet Explorer 2.
Endlich.
Das Rainbow Gift.
Du meinst das da.
Das Rainbow Gift war angesagt.
Kennt ihr noch dieses Gift von dem Typ.
So eine Rennanimation von so einem Dude.
Der so gerannt ist.
Das hatte man auch immer so.
Schnell ins Gästebuch.
Da hat man so einen Renntyp gemacht und sowas.
Und wisst ihr was ich ja total verstörend finde.
war ein GIF
der neuste Scheiß.
Und 2021 sind GIFs
immer noch voll angesagt.
Ich mein GIFs.
Alter.
Oder wie die coolen Leute sagen.
GIFs.
Ohne Mist hätte mir einer
1996 gesagt.
2021 verwenden
die Leute mehr GIFs als jemals
zuvor.
Das hätte ich dem nicht geglaubt.
Hätte ich den damals schon ausgelacht.
Hat der noch.
Kann man den irgendwie suchen.
EA.
Twitter.
Twitter gab es 1996 doch noch gar nicht.
So alt ist Twitter auch nicht.
Ach das ist.
Ah guck mal das ist Wikipedia
auf alt gemacht.
Aber es ist nicht wirklich alt.
Aber ey.
Genauso scheiße sahen damals
die Webseiten aus.
Okay.
EA
1997.
Boah.
Guck mal da versagt sogar.
Da versagt sogar der Darkreader
bei dieser Seite.
Was hat AOL eigentlich gemacht
das sie so abgekackt sind.
AOL war richtig
huge.
Flashbang.
Ey der Darkreader funktioniert hier nicht.
Ah jetzt doch.
Keine gratis CD mehr.
AOL
hatte ich angemeldet über meine Mutter
und über meinen Opa
und über meinen Vater.
Und dann bin ich drauf reingefallen.
Die Ultima Online Beta.
Und dann sind wir teilweise drauf reingefallen
das man es rechtzeitig kündigen muss.
Die haben gerade die www Seite
von Origin gefunden.
Interactive
Demos.
Wing Commander 1995.
Oh Mann.
Achja.
Und das hier das Encoding nicht
richtig funktioniert
hat.
Das war ja auch normal.
Webseiten Encoding war schon immer kaputt.
Spielst du nur Overwatch?
Ne.
Schon locker ein Jahr
nicht mehr.
Ich würde sogar sagen mittlerweile mehr.
Hacker Mode anmachen.
Ne.
Habe ich auch nicht mehr vor.
Und ich glaube auch nicht das Overwatch 2
etwas reißen wird.
Also die Blizzcon war ja echt enttäuschend.
Ich glaube das ist das Brightnet.
Das Gegenteil vom Darknet.
Oh ich habe letztens gecringed.
Ich habe Mittag gegessen und habe Radio
angemacht und dann kam irgendein
Typ im Radio und meinte
er erzählt uns jetzt
irgendwie 20 Facts
20 Facts
über das Internet.
Und da habe ich schon
da habe ich schon aufgehorcht
und ich dachte mir schon das wird Painschamp.
Er hat unter anderem erzählt
dass die 404 Fehlermeldung
daher kommt
weil im CERN der Raum mit den
Servern 404 drauf stand.
Also das denken viele
weil irgendwelche Leute mal angefangen haben
das zu verbreiten.
Also das habt ihr bestimmt auch schon gehört
diese Sache, dass es angeblich so wäre.
Aber das stimmt nicht.
Das ist nicht so.
Also das Gerücht gibt es schon ganz lange.
Aber das ist nicht so.
Das hat damit überhaupt
nichts zu tun.
Es war echt zum cringen.
Wusste nicht, dass es vom CERN
kommt. Doch.
Kommt vom CERN.
Also nicht das Internet
sondern
HTTP und Webbrowsing
Geschichten kommt daher.
Nein das hat mit dem
das hat mit dem Raum
überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Die HTTP Codes sind
durchnummeriert.
Typ.
400er sind permanente Fehler.
500er sind temporäre Fehler.
300 ist glaube ich
Redirection.
200 ist ok.
100 habe ich keine Ahnung, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Gibt es 100er HTTP Codes?
Ne das glaube ich nicht, dass es auf
Wikipedia drauf steht.
Auf Wikipedia steht bestimmt, dass das
eine Legende ist, die nicht stimmt.
Ah ok.
100er
Achso irgendwie so Websocket Upgrade
für uns. Ok.
HTTP Codes. Ok was ist das?
Hä?
Ich für die Next-Gen?
Ähm.
Naja also.
So wirklich hat es jetzt damit ja
nicht
ja nicht wirklich was zu tun
oder?
Also ich verstehe den Sinn der Seite, wobei man
sagen muss, dass es zum größten Teil
nicht so wirklich passt.
Bad Re... Ok das ist gut.
Hey das sieht fast aus wie Chico.
Ey das ist
das sieht original aus wie Chico.
Von der Farbe her, vom Schwanz her.
Das könnte meine sein.
Mein Teppichskin.
Naja.
Wie viele Seitenaufrufe macht der
Preischamp so?
Ich habe jetzt schon ein paar hunderttausend.
Ich glaube das letzte war
ich glaube 350.000
oder so hatte der jetzt ungefähr schon.
Und nichts
mehr.
Ich bin total charisiert ey.
Ich bezahle da sogar noch drauf.
Ja.
Du hast den Preischamp in Home Assistant eingebaut.
Excellent.
Ja ich muss euch aber mal jetzt ehrlich sagen,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie lang ich
den Preischamp noch betreibe, weil
also ich schalte den jetzt nicht
instant ab oder so.
Weil das Problem ist,
dass sich das zu pflegen
als doch etwas mehr Arbeit rausgestellt hat
Der Crawler, also
die Typen, die
das Repo vom
das Github Projekt von dem Crawler
betreiben, die sind nicht so
schnell, was deutsche Shops updaten angeht.
Also das heißt, eigentlich
müsste ich das
selbst machen und ich habe das ja mit
der Switch, mit der Switch habe ich es ja schon
selbst gemacht.
Die Switch habe ich selbst schon eingefügt.
Das hat ja funktioniert.
Aber ich habe keinen Bock
den Kram selbst zu pflegen. Ich habe auch
bei Alternate und Mindfactory total viel
selbst geupdatet und ich müsste eigentlich
permanent den Kram
Street Merchant
auf Github, was dahinter crawlt.
Ne, Amazon
ist mit Affiliate Links, der Rest
nicht. Ne, so dynamisch sind
die Seiten gar nicht.
Die Shop-Urls zu den Produkten sind immer die gleichen,
aber die Produkte wechseln halt öfters mal.
Guck, die Shop-Links sind
immer die gleichen. Siehst du hier unten, wenn du da drauf klickst,
kommst du bei Mindfactory raus.
Immer bei dieser Seite.
Aber die Produkte wechseln halt öfters mal
und deswegen...
Der Pflegeaufwand ist relativ hoch. Ich weiß nicht
ob ich
das lange...
Also ich werde es wahrscheinlich
laufen lassen, bis das Zeug wieder halbwegs verfügbar ist
und dann...
Splixer, das ist ja schon ein recht
großes Open Source Projekt. Die arbeiten lieber
beim Street Merchant direkt mit als bei mir.
Und...
Die sind halt nicht so hinterher.
Im Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass
mich der Kram ja auch 35 bis 40 Euro
im Monat kostet. Ich mein, das sind...
Es sind 3 Crawler-Server,
ein
Frontend-Server
und nen Analytics-Server.
Aber der kostet nur 2,50.
Ich wurde bei Heise erwähnt? Nee, oder?
Wer hat mich denn bei Heise erwähnt?
Bestimmt irgendwo im
Forum oder so.
Preisschamp. Jetzt hat wirklich einer
bei Heise was ins Forum geschrieben.
Das sind keine Affiliate-Links.
Nee, nur Amazon ist ein Affiliate-Link.
Wenn das alles... Also hätte ich überhaupt
nen Affiliate... Also die meisten
Shops haben teilweise
gar... Also außer
Alternate Mindfactory, glaube ich, haben die meisten Shops gar
keine...
äh...
Dings... Affiliate-Programme.
Und für Alternate und Mindfactory
will ich mich da nicht extra anmelden. Jetzt...
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube nicht, dass
sich das großartig lohnt. Da müsste ich das
wirklich für alles machen.
Nein, das track ich nicht. Ich tracke gar nix.
Ich tracke gar nix.
Das einzige, was mein Analytics
macht, ist Seitenaufrufe zählen.
Komplett ohne irgendwie
userbezogene Dinger.
Aber die Preise sind schon echt heftig, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an. 2.000...
Leute, es ist billiger geworden. Guckt mal, 7 Tage
billiger geworden. Von 3.000...
3.200...
Verkauft den doch. Wer soll das denn kaufen?
Äh... Von 3.200
rüber... Aber hier...
Da ist es... Da war es mal 2.200
und... Alter, die Preise... Aber für die Preisentwicklung
ist der Preisschamp tatsächlich ganz
cool. Also den Graph finde ich zum Beispiel
viel aussagekräftiger als, jetzt sagen wir mal,
bei Mindfair... Äh... Bei Guides halt oder so.
PC King kann ich... Äh...
Doch, PC King ist drinne.
Ne, Case King.
Case King geht nicht.
PC King ist drinne.
Allerdings wahrscheinlich nicht die richtigen Rules
zur Grafikkarte.
Doppelklick auf den Keks öffnet
Save PNG. Was?
Doppelklick
auf den Keks ist, äh...
zum den Chat blind zu machen.
Flashbang.
Hardware hat... Ne.
Die verkaufen ja auch keine einzelnen
Sachen. Ich habe den extra
gefragt, ob er will.
Aber ich meine, das lohnt sich nicht.
Verkaufen quasi nichts einzeln.
Preisschamp.org. Ok.
Machen wir mal Google-Suche, ob mich jemand erwähnt hat.
Die letzte...
Letzte Woche?
Ne, nur Reddit.
Reddit.
Hat mich erwähnt. Reddit.
Ah, ne, hier. Golem.
Ne, ne, sind keine 8-Server.
Drei Crawler, also...
Drei
Triple-Core-Crawler,
ein Dual-Core-Web-Frontend
und ein Single-Core-Analytic
ist der Preisschamp.
Kostet aber halt trotzdem 40 Euro im Monat.
Exquisite Hackermans.
Also letzten Monat hatte ich
99 Euro. Klatt.
99 Euro Serverkosten bei Hetzner.
Aber das waren auch die ganzen Versuche
mit dabei, mit den 16-Core-Kisten und so.
So, jetzt guck ich doch mal
Questions rein.
Der Traffic kostet erstmal nix.
Ab 20 Terabyte
kostet das was.
Allerdings bezieht sich das auf
über 20 Terabyte
ich glaube
ausgehend
wahrscheinlich
wollen die nicht, dass man von dort irgendwelche komischen
Dinger macht.
Ich glaube
Inbound-Traffic oder umgedreht war immer
umsonst. Also im Prinzip
im Prinzip ist der Traffic
nahezu Unlimited.
Macht er
der Auer?
Der Bauer nicht Werbung
für Hetzner, doch.
Doch. Contabo ist auch
nicht günstiger als Hetzner.
Kostet sogar
noch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
mehr. Und
die machen einen riesen Akt mit
Personalausweis
Identität bestätigen, Personalausweis
Hetzner ist da total
unkompliziert.
Das Hetzner RZ virtuell betreten
geht das? Wart mal.
Hetzner RZ
Haben die so einen Rundgang?
Hast du mal einen Link? Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Hier.
360 Tour. Hier das Hetzner RZ
Sieht aus wie eine Tankstelle von außen
oder? Worauf empfiehlst
du Home Automation zu hosten? Also
wenn du es auf dem Raspberry Pi hostest
dann
nur mit SSD
sonst ist es zu lahm.
Ich habe es auf einer Low Power Quad Core
Inhalt Kiste, wo auch mal ganzes andere Zeug
läuft. Okay. Wir machen jetzt Rundgang
bei Hetzner.
Aber man kann nicht mal mit WASD laufen.
Oh.
Moment. Es gibt nur 4 Bilder. Ist das
ernsthaft? Nur 4
Ist das alles?
Okay.
Wo geht es da rein? Hier lang?
Alles klar.
Okay.
Okay. Wo geht es rein?
Ich will ins RZ. Hier.
Hetzner.
Die Bedienung davon
ist aber ziemlich sackig.
Und die hätten das mal unbedingt an einem schönen Tag
aufnehmen sollen.
So rein Marketing technisch jetzt.
Aha. Erst mal kurz
Nummernschild vom Chef angucken.
Oh. Bin schon jetzt gelandet.
Hier kommt man wieder
raus.
Ich will nicht bei Hetzner rein. Ich will
dahin. Ah. Geht nicht.
Oh. Jetzt gehen wir bei Hetzner im Hintereingang rein.
Hier geht nicht weiter.
Okay.
Okay. Was war denn das?
Hetzner online. We love bits. Do you?
Ah. Da kann man sich als Professioneller
Display lecker
bewerben.
Ah. Yes.
Okay. Jetzt gehen wir da rein.
Hier geht es nicht weiter.
Ich habe so den Tick auch bei Games.
Ich laufe immer dahin,
wo das Spiel nicht will, dass ich hin laufe.
So.
Da geht es rein.
Eine Runde Hetzner Werbevideo.
Excellent.
Da geht es. Einladendste
Warteecke aller Zeiten. Ey.
Hahaha.
Da würde ich ja
gerne warten.
Nur eine Sackkarre
in der Ecke. Und ihr Empfang
äußerst
eine einladende Warteecke.
Stell dir mal vor, du gehst da rein.
So hast du dich da beworben. Ja. Nehmen sie hier mal kurz Platz
und machen sie es sich bequem.
Oh ja.
Zum Glück haben sie die Türen
aufgemalt, dass du nicht die Türen gegen den Kopf gehauen
kriegst.
Du kannst die Türen nicht ins Gesicht gehauen bekommen.
Es sei denn, einer macht die Seite auf.
Okay. Wo geht es weiter?
Ah. Guck mal. Da kann man
rein. Da kann man rein.
Wir gehen zum Notausgang.
Äh.
Ach. Da kommen wir her.
Jetzt haben die aber cool gemacht.
Ah. Ne. Hier darf man nicht.
Ah. Und hier darf man auch nicht weiter. Okay.
Ah. Yes.
Rechenzentrum.
Excellent. Excellent.
Guck mal. Sogar
Sogar
zweistöckiges Adset.
Wisst ihr wie das aussieht?
Das sieht aus
wie die Fabrikhalle aus
Warzone.
Oder alternativ wie die Fabrikhalle
auf Battlefield 3
auf auf auf
dieser einen
DLC Map.
Diese Herbst DLC Map.
Ich habe vergessen wie sie heißt.
Sieht genau so aus.
Nice.
Die hätten aber die Steuerung
unbedingt mit Tastatur machen müssen.
Ach. Man kann hier nicht weiter.
Aber guck mal hier.
Ganz viele exquisite
Netzwerkkabel.
Das ist das Adset mal weiter an.
Zack. Daneben dürfen wir nicht lang.
Äh. Wo gehts runter?
Okay. Adset.
Hier dürfen wir nicht durch.
Dürfen nur dahin.
Okay. Ich sehe
viele Netzteile.
Gut. Das ist irgendwas von hinten.
Dürfen wir mal in so einen Würfel reingucken?
Klimaanlage.
Ah. Wir dürfen sogar reingucken.
Ja gut. Sieht halt. Okay.
Was zum?
Was ist das?
Was?
Was bin ich sehend?
Ein Desktop Mainboard mit VGA?
Ja. Ich würde sagen. Ein Desktop
Mainboard mit
VGA und DVI.
Die verwenden keine Rack Hardware.
Ja. Das habe ich auch schon gelesen.
Und ich finde die Idee gar nicht so doof.
Ich finde die Idee gar nicht so doof.
Ähm.
Weil du kannst die Desktop Hardware
so easy tauschen.
Wenn da mal einer ausfällt. Ist nicht so wild.
Und es ist wahrscheinlich einfach
viel viel billiger.
Ich würde das auch.
Ehrlich. Ohne Scheiß.
Ich würde es auch so machen.
Hast du das Adset nicht neulich erst begutachten?
Ne. Also wenn ich sowas anbieten würde.
Oder wenn ich irgendwas. Das würde ich auch so machen.
Ja. Das ist das Adset von Hetzner.
Ah. Ich dachte
man könnte auch ein bisschen anderweitig durchlaufen.
Warte.
Ich muss hier raus. Sonst verliere ich die Orientierung.
Da kommen wir her.
Aha.
Netzteil Action.
Huge Netzteile.
Ach. Hier geht es dann gar nicht mehr weiter.
Das ist. Sehe ich das richtig.
Es gibt nur den Anfang vom Adset.
Mehr gibt es nicht.
Hier waren wir ja schon drin.
Hier waren wir schon.
Ja. Ich bin so sehr in der Cloud.
Dass ich gerade sogar durchs
Cloud Rechenzentrum laufen kann.
Man muss sich ja. Man muss sich hier merken.
Wo man. Wo man lang geht.
Ok. Das ist verwirrend.
So. Da waren wir jetzt schon drin. Da war der Eingang.
Und irgendwo konnte man jetzt noch rein.
Das ist jetzt ein anderes.
Ne.
Das ist das Hetzner Rechenzentrum.
Cooling.
Äh.
Keck. Keck. Wait.
Ah. Ne. Ne. Ne.
Wait a minute. Da.
Also hier geht es. Hier geht es wieder.
Da ist ja die Bodenplatte draußen.
Da wo er steht.
Warum genau ist da die Bodenplatte draußen?
Das ist Glas. Echt. Warum?
Das ist kein Glas.
Hier siehst du doch neben direkt das
Auflagending.
Stimmt. Die Deckenlampe spiegelt sich.
Ich habe jetzt gedacht. Die spiegelt sich da unten.
Spiegelt sich tatsächlich hier oben.
Excellent. Excellent.
Hier ging es raus. Oder?
Ja. Ok.
Hier geht es weiter.
So.
Gut.
Sieht so halt aus.
Dürfen wir hier auch weiter?
Ach hier. Warte. Ok.
Wir haben. Danach haben wir alles gesehen.
Darf ich ein Rack aufmachen please?
Ich will da rein gucken.
Das sind jetzt. Ok. Das sind jetzt 19 Zoll
Dinger.
Darf ich einen Schrank. Ich will einen Schrank aufmachen.
Das hätte noch. Das wäre noch cool.
Hätte man noch einen Schrank aufmachen können.
Fühle ich mich fast. Fühle ich mich fast wie äh.
Beim echten Rechenzentrums
Rundgang.
Ok. Mehr geht nicht.
Yep.
Haben wir hier ein Loch?
Oh. Ist da ein Loch?
Raised Floors
Ja doppelt.
Das ist aber so. Diese Zwischenböden sind ja.
Das ist ja normal.
Das hat eigentlich fast jedes Headset.
Ah.
Das ist das allerwichtigste.
Gut zu wissen, dass das hier ist.
Ähnlich.
Eine Runde Kacken bei Hetzner.
Wollte ich schon immer mal.
Falls ich jemals da bin.
Das wichtigste ist schon mal.
Geregelt.
Ah hier.
Ok. Das sieht tatsächlich jetzt ein bisschen einladender aus.
Die Warteecke.
Im Oldschool Telefon.
Ein bisschen Bunkermäßig.
Sieht es ja aus.
Aber immerhin. Hier hängt so moderne Kunst an der Wand.
Das lockert die Atmosphäre auf.
Man darf nicht fotografieren.
Ok. Login.
Login ist raus Leute.
Ob die QR-Code Fehlerkorrektur
so gut ist, dass man das scannen kann?
Also QR-Code Fehlerkorrektur
ist echt Poggers.
Aber ne. Ey. Da erkennt er selbst
nix drauf.
Ne.
Da erkennt er nix drauf.
Keine Chance.
Ich probier es gerade mit meinem Handy.
Klappt nicht.
Wär cool. Aber QR-Code.
Also QR. Ohne Mist.
QR-Code Fehler.
Fehlerkorrektur ist echt hart.
Also glaubt man manchmal gar nicht, wie gut die das erkennen.
So. Eine Runde.
Kaffeestelz.
Oh. Hier kann man um die Ecke gucken.
Was ist hier?
Ah. Guck mal. Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Sieht ja fast aus wie bei mir.
Das ist aber die einsamste Technik der Ecke.
Des ganzen Ladens hier. Oder?
Was macht man? Für was genau ist das?
Was ist der Sinn davon?
Aufnahmeprüfung.
Meint ihr man nimmt einfach einen Rollwagen
zieht den Kram raus
der kaputt ist und repariert das dann hier um die Ecke?
Ich mein wär ganz sinnvoll bevor man da sonst wo hin fährt.
Aber das sieht so
So karg irgendwie und
Ja keine Ahnung.
Okay, wir haben das Headset der Rechenzentrum gesehen.
Mehr gibt's nicht.
Oh, ne.
Hä, wie bin...
Wir haben manche Wege...
Leute, wir haben die Wege nicht gefunden.
Hier ist das Loading-Dock.
Data Center, Co-Location.
Da waren wir drin.
Cafeteria.
Oh!
Как wait?
Wie sind die da jetzt hingekommen?
Moment.
Wie?
Welche Tür ging hier?
Aha!
Da muss man von der anderen Seite rein.
Okay, die Bedienung verwirrt mich übelst.
Da kommt man auf die Rampe, okay.
Rampenstelz.
Und hier gehen die Treppen wieder hoch.
Ups.
Da geht's in die Cafeteria hoch.
Ja gut, kein Wunder, dass wir das nicht gefunden haben.
Da kamen wir aus dem RZ aus nicht hin.
Bisschen wenig Leute hier überall, oder?
Ich hab nicht eine Person gesehen bisher.
Na gut, klar, die sind aus dem Bild gegangen, aber trotzdem.
Der obligatorische Tischkicker, den wahrscheinlich keiner verwendet.
Der muss aber einfach da sein, weil irgendwie viele so IT-Unternehmen der Meinung sind Tischkicker.
Alle wollen sie Tischkickern und im Endeffekt Tischkicker dann auch keiner, so.
Ah, yes.
Huge Raucherecke.
Da steht der Bus mit China-Touristen davor.
Okay, nice.
So sieht's bei Hetzner also aus.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
ISO 27001.
Zertifiziert, na dann.
Mustang-Fahrer, Stufe 1, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Sub.
Jet IQ increase.
Was, stand da Knabenchor?
Wirklich?
Da, der Papst freut sich.
So, erstmal hier alles zumachen.
Blub.
Erstmal alles schließen.
Alles schließen, zack, zack, zack.
Und ganz wichtig.
Äh, VM.
VM löschen.
Ja, also.
Die ZFS-Geschichte jetzt nochmal zusammenzufassen finde ich echt nice, wie sie es mittlerweile
gemacht haben.
Ist relativ easy, aber der Install, aber der Install-Vorgang, äh, nervt mich immer noch.
Das, also, das würde ich nicht benutzen, also nicht mit dem Installer und nicht standardmäßig
so auf, ähm, auf meiner Kiste hier, aber an sich haben sie es schon cool gemacht.
Oh, Mist, ich muss die Fragen ja noch schnell durchgehen.
Schnell wieder anschalten.
Null.
Ja, ja, EZ, EZ-Kosten, viel.
Wir bezahlen für unser Backup-Rechenzentrum auf der Arbeit 30.000 Euro Stromkosten im Monat.
Habe ich letztens irgendwo gehört.
Kannst du das Ganze nicht über Ansible machen?
Boah, das, was ich heute gemacht habe über Ansible-Skripten, stell ich mir ein bisschen
schwierig vor.
Das komplette Debian-Setup und die, mit den Reboots und alles, ne.
CloudHQ in Offenbach.
Kenn ich nicht.
Aber, schadet auf jeden Fall nix.
Mehr Alternativen ist immer nicht verkehrt.
Es gab ja mal das Gerücht, dass in Hanau Amazon ein Rechenzentrum, also, ein, ähm,
nicht ein Rechenzentrum aufmacht, so ein Gewerbegebiet komplett kauft und da was aufmacht.
Habe ich schon überlegt, Bewerbung bei Amazon ist raus, null, aber das wäre wahrscheinlich
nur irgendein Cloud-Standort geworden und da, ne.
Absolut nicht.
Habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Weil Amazon-Techniker will ich nicht sein.
Also Amazon, äh, Sackkarren-Fahrer.
Mehr hätte es an der Stelle nicht gegeben.
Host Unlimited, da haben wir doch mal ein Video geguckt von irgend so einem Kerl, der,
der, ich glaube das war Host Unlimited, auf YouTube.
Nein, habe ich nicht gespielt, ich habe es vor, aber erst, wenn ich mir eine 3D-Brille
mal irgendwann kaufen sollte.
Naja, gut.
Pff.
Das kann ja großartig passieren, ne.
Du musst ja da immer noch reinkommen.
Und wenn, hast du trotzdem keine Ahnung, wo was drauf ist, also, ich glaube nicht, dass
das so wild ist.
Und die haben sicherlich noch ein paar Räume, die sie nicht gezeigt haben, wo die Stonksachen
sind.
Ähm, das ist Manjaro mit i3-WM, das kannst du gar nicht runterladen, du musst Manjaro
installieren und dann dir ein i3-WM einrichten.
Ich glaube, es gibt sogar ein offizielles i3-Manjaro-Flavor mittlerweile, aber das hat
mir nicht gefallen.
Ja.
Deswegen hat die Blizzcon auch gesagt.
i3 Mega S hatte ich.
Home Assistant habe ich, wie gesagt, in einer VM auf einer Low-Power-Quad-Core-Intel-Kiste.
Ich glaube, bezieht sich alles auf die Deluxe-Installation.
Ah, jetzt bin ich durch.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Chat, ich gehe ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns.
Ciao.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
War eine recht spontane Geschichte.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
Oh, krass.